Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. When you come back to England from any foreign country, you have immediately the sensation of breathing a different air. Even in the first few minutes, dozens of small things conspire to give you this feeling. The beer is bitterer, the coins are heavier, the grass is greener, the advertisements are more blatant.
Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. When you come back to England from any foreign country, you have immediately the sensation of breathing a different air. Even in the first few minutes, dozens of small things conspire to give you this feeling. The beer is bitterer, the coins are heavier, the grass is greener, the advertisements are more blatant.|||感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要每周获取独家播客节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。当你从任何外国回到英格兰时，你立刻会有一种呼吸到不同空气的感觉。甚至在最初的几分钟里，几十件小事共同作用，带给你这种感觉。啤酒更苦了，硬币更重了，草更绿了，广告也更明目张胆了。
The crowds in the big towns with their mild knobby faces, their bad teeth and gentle manners are different from a European crowd. Then the vastness of England swallows you up and you lose for a while your feeling that the whole nation has a single identifiable character. Are there really such things as nations? Are we not 46 million individuals or different? And the diversity of it, the chaos, the clatter of clogs in the Lancashire mill towns, the to and fro of the lorries on the Great North Road, the queues outside the labour exchanges, the rattle of pin tables in the Soho pubs, the old maids hiking to Holy Communion through the mists of the autumn morning.
The crowds in the big towns with their mild knobby faces, their bad teeth and gentle manners are different from a European crowd. Then the vastness of England swallows you up and you lose for a while your feeling that the whole nation has a single identifiable character. Are there really such things as nations? Are we not 46 million individuals or different? And the diversity of it, the chaos, the clatter of clogs in the Lancashire mill towns, the to and fro of the lorries on the Great North Road, the queues outside the labour exchanges, the rattle of pin tables in the Soho pubs, the old maids hiking to Holy Communion through the mists of the autumn morning.|||大城市里的人群有着温和而骨感面容、糟糕的牙齿和温和的举止，这与欧洲人群截然不同。接着，英格兰的辽阔将你吞没，你暂时失去了“整个国家拥有单一可辨识性格”的感觉。真的有国家这种东西吗？我们难道不是4600万个各不相同的个体吗？还有那里的多样性、混乱、兰开夏郡纺织镇上木鞋的咔哒声、大北路上货车的往来、劳动力交易所外的长队、苏荷区酒吧里弹珠台的碰撞声、老处女们顶着秋日早晨的薄雾徒步去参加圣餐礼。
All these are not only fragments, but characteristic fragments of the English scene. How can one make a pattern out of this muddle? So Tom Holland, that was friend of the show, George Orwell, writing during the Blitz, probably the single most famous evocation of England and Englishness ever written. And it strikes me that every single element of it is now utterly out of date. Do you think that's fair? I think that's a bit harsh because he's talking about the diversity of England. And if anything, England's become, I mean, clearly become infinitely more diverse than when Orwell was writing about it. And yet I think there is still a sense of what,
All these are not only fragments, but characteristic fragments of the English scene. How can one make a pattern out of this muddle? So Tom Holland, that was friend of the show, George Orwell, writing during the Blitz, probably the single most famous evocation of England and Englishness ever written. And it strikes me that every single element of it is now utterly out of date. Do you think that's fair? I think that's a bit harsh because he's talking about the diversity of England. And if anything, England's become, I mean, clearly become infinitely more diverse than when Orwell was writing about it. And yet I think there is still a sense of what,|||所有这些不仅是片段，而且是英格兰风景的标志性片段。人们怎么能从这团混乱中理出头绪呢？汤姆·霍兰德，那是节目的老朋友，乔治·奥威尔在闪电战期间写下的文字，或许是有史以来对英格兰和英格兰性最著名的描绘。我觉得它的每一个元素现在都彻底过时了。你觉得这公道吗？我觉得这有点刻薄，因为他在谈论英格兰的多样性。如果要说的话，英格兰已经——我是说，显然变得比奥威尔写作时无限多元化。然而我认为仍然有一种感觉，
I mean, England still has a place in the imagination of those who live in the country that is called England. So to that extent, I think he is onto something. I mean, obviously, all the stuff about old maid cycling to communion and the clatter of clogs on Lancashire streets, I mean, that's gone. But plus ça change, c'est la même chose, as Orwell would doubtless have put it. He would definitely not have. There was no way he would have put that. I mean, basically, are there continuities from the present through to the mid-20th century, when always writing that, that go further back or not? I mean, great question.
I mean, England still has a place in the imagination of those who live in the country that is called England. So to that extent, I think he is onto something. I mean, obviously, all the stuff about old maid cycling to communion and the clatter of clogs on Lancashire streets, I mean, that's gone. But plus ça change, c'est la même chose, as Orwell would doubtless have put it. He would definitely not have. There was no way he would have put that. I mean, basically, are there continuities from the present through to the mid-20th century, when always writing that, that go further back or not? I mean, great question.|||我是说，对于生活在这个被称为英格兰的国家里的人们来说，英格兰在他们的想象中仍然有一席之地。所以在某种程度上，我认为他确实说准了某些东西。我是说，很明显，所有关于老处女骑自行车去参加圣餐礼以及兰开夏郡街头木鞋咔哒声的事情，我是说，那些都已经消失了。但“越变越不变”（plus ça change, c'est la même chose），正如奥威尔毫无疑问会说的那样。他绝对不会这么说。他绝不可能那么说。我的意思是，从现在到20世纪中叶奥威尔写作时的时期，是否存在一直延续到更早时期的连贯性？这是一个极好的问题。
Well, it's a question about all nations. But what makes it particularly interesting about England is that England is one of the most famous examples of a nation that is not a nation state. So, you know, England has no seat at the United Nations General Assembly. A lot of people who live in England do not describe themselves as English. They say they're British. But abroad, of course, everybody typically confuses England and Britain, as we often do ourselves, don't we? I think less so, though. So I think that's another feature is that uh the sense the english have of themselves within a nation called the united kingdom has definitely grown
Well, it's a question about all nations. But what makes it particularly interesting about England is that England is one of the most famous examples of a nation that is not a nation state. So, you know, England has no seat at the United Nations General Assembly. A lot of people who live in England do not describe themselves as English. They say they're British. But abroad, of course, everybody typically confuses England and Britain, as we often do ourselves, don't we? I think less so, though. So I think that's another feature is that uh the sense the english have of themselves within a nation called the united kingdom has definitely grown|||嗯，这是一个关于所有国家的问题。但关于英格兰特别有趣的一点是，英格兰是“不是民族国家”的民族中最著名的例子之一。所以，你知道，英格兰在联合国大会上没有席位。许多住在英格兰的人并不认为自己是英格兰人。他们说自己是英国人。但在国外，当然，每个人通常都会混淆英格兰和英国，就像我们自己也经常这样做一样，不是吗？不过我觉得现在少多了。所以我认为另一个特征是，呃，英格兰人在一个被称为联合王国的国家里对自己的认同感确实增强了
over the past decade it has indeed yeah and so somebody who's been a great observer of this tom or are you going to introduce him because you i, have played cricket with him, I guess. I have. So few things are more archetypally English than a game of cricket on a summer green. And I played cricket with Jason on one of the most famous days in recent English history, which was the day of the death of Princess Diana. And the game went ahead, but in a rather embarrassed way. So I remember we lined up outside the pavilion, which had a flagpole and the flagpole was at half mast and we all stood there and we didn't really know what to do. So we took our caps off and twisted them in an
over the past decade it has indeed yeah and so somebody who's been a great observer of this tom or are you going to introduce him because you i, have played cricket with him, I guess. I have. So few things are more archetypally English than a game of cricket on a summer green. And I played cricket with Jason on one of the most famous days in recent English history, which was the day of the death of Princess Diana. And the game went ahead, but in a rather embarrassed way. So I remember we lined up outside the pavilion, which had a flagpole and the flagpole was at half mast and we all stood there and we didn't really know what to do. So we took our caps off and twisted them in an|||在过去的十年里确实如此，是的。所以作为一个对此有伟大洞察的观察者，汤姆，还是你要介绍他？因为你，我猜你和他一起打过板球。我打过。因此，没有什么比在夏日的草坪上打一场板球更能代表英格兰的典型特征了。我和杰森在英格兰近代史上最著名的一天一起打过板球，也就是戴安娜王妃逝世的那天。比赛照常进行，但方式相当尴尬。我记得我们在凉亭外排队，那里有一根旗杆，旗杆挂着半旗，我们都站在那里，真的不知道该做些什么。于是我们脱下帽子，尴尬地扭着，戴上，
embarrassed way, put them on, and then we just kind of shuffled off, which I thought was a, I think Orwell would probably have recognized the uh he definitely the quality of embarrassment there but am I not also right in thinking that you had a very a ferocious you were ferociously upbraided by your captain yeah so we then went on to um to play the match and um and the captain we haven't even let him speak yet we haven't even we haven't even introduced him the captain who for now will remain nameless his his idea of man management was as i was bowling to yell at me you're losing us the match and the more tense i got the more abusive he became and i knew then that he was destined for great thing and sure enough he went on to edit the new statesman displaying his his
embarrassed way, put them on, and then we just kind of shuffled off, which I thought was a, I think Orwell would probably have recognized the uh he definitely the quality of embarrassment there but am I not also right in thinking that you had a very a ferocious you were ferociously upbraided by your captain yeah so we then went on to um to play the match and um and the captain we haven't even let him speak yet we haven't even we haven't even introduced him the captain who for now will remain nameless his his idea of man management was as i was bowling to yell at me you're losing us the match and the more tense i got the more abusive he became and i knew then that he was destined for great thing and sure enough he went on to edit the new statesman displaying his his|||然后我们只是拖着脚步离开，我认为这是一个——我想奥威尔大概会认出那种呃，他绝对能认出那种尴尬的特质。不过我是不是也想得没错，你曾遭到过极其严厉的——你被你的队长极其严厉地训斥了一顿？是的，然后我们继续去……去打比赛，然后——这位队长，我们甚至还没让他说话呢，我们甚至还没有——我们甚至还没介绍他，这位目前暂且匿名得队长，他的团队管理理念就是，当我正在投球时冲我大喊：“你正在让我们输掉比赛！”我越紧张，他就越辱骂我，我当时就知道他注定成就大业，果不其然，他后来去编辑了《新政治家》杂志，展现了他——
ability for leadership and it is of course the great jason cowley one of the the great editors of our age being at the helm of the new statesman for how long now jason 20 years um it feels like 20 years 13 tom 13 years and before that you uh you great sports journalist uh at the helm of um the observer sports uh weekly when they had that yeah it was a monthly. Oh, it was a monthly, wasn't it? And then I edited Granter for a year, a literary quarterly. So Jason, finger on the absolute pulse of English and dare one say British culture.
ability for leadership and it is of course the great jason cowley one of the the great editors of our age being at the helm of the new statesman for how long now jason 20 years um it feels like 20 years 13 tom 13 years and before that you uh you great sports journalist jason at the helm of um the observer sports uh weekly when they had that yeah it was a monthly. Oh, it was a monthly, wasn't it? And then I edited Granter for a year, a literary quarterly. So Jason, finger on the absolute pulse of English and dare one say British culture.|||的领导能力。他当然就是伟大的杰森·考利（Jason Cowley），我们这个时代伟大的编辑之一，掌舵《新政治家》杂志多久了？杰森。20年。嗯，感觉像20年。13年，汤姆，13年。在此之前，你——伟大的体育记者杰森，曾掌舵……《观察家报》体育周刊，当他们有那个的时候。是的，那是一份月刊。哦，那是一份月刊，对吧？然后我主编了《格兰塔》（Granta）一年，这是一份文学季刊。所以杰森，你绝对把握住了英格兰乃至——敢这么说的话——英国文化的脉搏。
So you've got a book that is, I suppose, in a way, the fruit of many decades of reflection on the subject of Englishness and England called Who Are We Now? Stories of Modern England. Jason, who are we now? It's a good question, Tom. And thank you for having me on the show. It's a great honour to be on this wonderful podcast. And thank you for reminding me of my captaincy back in the day. And that was actually a quintessentially Orwellian scene because it was a village called Hatfield Heath, very close to Hatfield Forest in the day. That was actually a quintessentially Orwellian scene because it was a village called Hatfield Heath, very close to Hatfield Forest in Essex. And beautiful late September day, if I recall. And it was a sort of gentleman and players encounter.
So you've got a book that is, I suppose, in a way, the fruit of many decades of reflection on the subject of Englishness and England called Who Are We Now? Stories of Modern England. Jason, who are we now? It's a good question, Tom. And thank you for having me on the show. It's a great honour to be on this wonderful podcast. And thank you for reminding me of my captaincy back in the day. And that was actually a quintessentially Orwellian scene because it was a village called Hatfield Heath, very close to Hatfield Forest in the day. That was actually a quintessentially Orwellian scene because it was a village called Hatfield Heath, very close to Hatfield Forest in Essex. And beautiful late September day, if I recall. And it was a sort of gentleman and players encounter.|||所以你出了一本书，我想在某种程度上，它是几十年来对英格兰性和英格兰主题反思的结晶，书名叫作《我们现在是谁？现代英格兰的故事》（Who Are We Now? Stories of Modern England）。杰森，我们现在是谁？这是一个好问题，汤姆。谢谢你邀请我上节目。能参加这个精彩的播客深感荣幸。谢谢你提醒我当年当队长的事。那其实是一个典型的奥威尔式场景，因为那是一个叫哈特菲尔德希思的村庄，当时离埃塞克斯的哈特菲尔德森林非常近。那实际上是一个典型的奥威尔式场景，因为那是哈特菲尔德希思的一个村庄，离埃塞克斯的哈特菲尔德森林很近。如果我没记错的话，那是九月下旬美丽的一天。那是一种绅士与球员的交锋。
Your brother turned up in an open top classic car and a lot of posh Oxbridge types appeared alongside you, of which I am not one. And then on the opposition were a group of local village cricketers. And the guy who took a liking to your bowling late in the game, actually, Tom, you were bowling your accurate medium pieces. A quick medium, I think. Fast medium. Fast medium. The local blacksmith sort of took to them with relish. And they were appearing either over the boundary without bouncing or one bounce.
Your brother turned up in an open top classic car and a lot of posh Oxbridge types appeared alongside you, of which I am not one. And then on the opposition were a group of local village cricketers. And the guy who took a liking to your bowling late in the game, actually, Tom, you were bowling your accurate medium pieces. A quick medium, I think. Fast medium. The local blacksmith sort of took to them with relish. And they were appearing either over the boundary without bouncing or one bounce.|||你弟弟开着一辆敞篷经典跑车出现，许多时髦的牛津剑桥类型的人出现在你身旁，而我并非其中之一。然后对手是一群当地的乡村板球运动员。在比赛后段看中你投球的那个人，事实上，汤姆，你当时投的是精准的中速球。快中速，我想。快中速。当地的铁匠津津有味地接下了这些球。它们要末直接飞过边界而没有落地，要末落地一次。
But Jason, I'd lost it in the mind. It's a game played in the mind and you shredded my self-confidence with your man management skills. Indeed. I did ask you to be canny, didn't I, if I recall? Yes, you did. You did. Anyway, Dominic began with Orwell. Dominic, I think that was from The Lion and the Unicorn, wasn't it?
But Jason, I'd lost it in the mind. It's a game played in the mind and you shredded my self-confidence with your man management skills. Indeed. I did ask you to be canny, didn't I, if I recall? Yes, you did. You did. Anyway, Dominic began with Orwell. Dominic, I think that was from The Lion and the Unicorn, wasn't it?|||但杰森，我当时心态崩溃了。这是一场在心理上进行的比赛，而你用你的团队管理技巧撕碎了我的自信心。确实如此。我确实要求你机灵点，不是吗，如果我没记错的话？是的，你确实说了。你确实说了。不管怎样，多米尼克从奥威尔开始谈起。多米尼克，我想那出自《狮子与独角兽》（The Lion and the Unicorn），对吧？
It was, yeah. Which Orwell wrote in, began in the spring of 1940 and was shot in the throat on the Aragon front and almost died. And when he comes back from Barcelona, where he feels the Republican government has betrayed the cause, taking their orders from Stalin, Soviet Union, and he certainly believed that, he comes back and the book ends with this wonderful vision of England in the south of England. And he speaks about England being sleeping the deep, deep sleep of England. But he's warning them that the English people are about to be awoken by the roar of bombs. And I think when Orwell was writing in 1940, he's writing about Britain rather than just England,
It was, yeah. Which Orwell wrote in, began in the spring of 1940 and was shot in the throat on the Aragon front and almost died. And when he comes back from Barcelona, where he feels the Republican government has betrayed the cause, taking their orders from Stalin, Soviet Union, and he certainly believed that, he comes back and the book ends with this wonderful vision of England in the south of England. And he speaks about England being sleeping the deep, deep sleep of England. But he's warning them that the English people are about to be awoken by the roar of bombs. And I think when Orwell was writing in 1940, he's writing about Britain rather than just England,|||是的，确实如此。奥威尔在1940年春天开始写作此书，后来在阿拉贡前线喉部中枪，差点丧命。当他从巴塞罗那回来时，他感到共和政府背叛了事业，听命于斯大林的苏联，他对此深信不疑。他回来后，这本书以对英格兰南部英格兰的美妙愿景结束。他谈到英格兰正在沉睡，陷入英格兰深深的沉睡中。但他警告他们，英格兰人民即将被炸弹的轰鸣声唤醒。我认为当奥威尔在1940年写作时，他写的是大不列颠，而不仅仅是英格兰，
but he uses England. So what you spoke about at the beginning of this sense of England being lost within Britishness, or the two being interchangeable. But at that point in September 1940, what was bringing the nation together was a sense of encroaching threat, was danger. After Dunkirk, Orwell knew what had to be done. The army had to be brought home and the invasion had to be stopped. And this was a clarifying moment for Orwell. It had always been deeply ambivalent about his relationship with England and Englishness. He was an old Etonian, but he hated the public schools. He served as a policeman in Burma and loathed the empire. But at the same time, he loathed the left and what he called book-trained socialism. So here was this very quarrelsome and sceptical
but he uses England. So what you spoke about at the beginning of this sense of England being lost within Britishness, or the two being interchangeable. But at that point in September 1940, what was bringing the nation together was a sense of encroaching threat, was danger. After Dunkirk, Orwell knew what had to be done. The army had to be brought home and the invasion had to be stopped. And this was a clarifying moment for Orwell. It had always been deeply ambivalent about his relationship with England and Englishness. He was an old Etonian, but he hated the public schools. He served as a policeman in Burma and loathed the empire. But at the same time, he loathed the left and what he called book-trained socialism. So here was this very quarrelsome and sceptical|||但他用的是“英格兰”。所以正如你在开头谈到的那样，英格兰在英国性中迷失的感觉，或者这两者是可以互换的。但在1940年9月那个时刻，将整个国家凝聚在一起的是一种不断逼近的威胁感，是危险。敦刻尔克之后，奥威尔知道必须做些什么。军队必须撤回国内，入侵必须被阻止。对奥威尔来说，这是一个澄清的时刻。他对英格兰及英格兰性的关系一直感到深深的矛盾。他曾是伊顿公学的老生，但他讨厌公学。他曾在缅甸担任警察，却痛恨帝国。但与此同时，他痛恨左翼以及他所谓的书本式社会主义。所以这里有这样一个争强好胜且充满怀疑精神的
figure, and suddenly he has this clarifying moment. This is England. What is England? And how do we make the nation cohere and come together and find a sense of unity, a moment of heightened peril and danger of a kind, actually, in completely different circumstances that we're seeing in Ukraine? A form of Ukrainian national identity is being formed in war, as it was for the English in 1940 into 1941, which was when Orwell wrote that wonderful essay. So you obviously think there is an England. I mean, your book is all about it. But Englishness, so let's say 30 or 40 years ago, no one wrote about England or Englishness. I mean, it was a question that simply was never raised, wasn't it?
figure, and suddenly he has this clarifying moment. This is England. What is England? And how do we make the nation cohere and come together and find a sense of unity, a moment of heightened peril and danger of a kind, actually, in completely different circumstances that we're seeing in Ukraine? A form of Ukrainian national identity is being formed in war, as it was for the English in 1940 into 1941, which was when Orwell wrote that wonderful essay. So you obviously think there is an England. I mean, your book is all about it. But Englishness, so let's say 30 or 40 years ago, no one wrote about England or Englishness. I mean, it was a question that simply was never raised, wasn't it?|||人物，突然间他迎来了这个豁然开朗的时刻。这就是英格兰。什么是英格兰？我们如何让这个国家凝聚在一起、团结起来并找到一种团结感？这实际上是一种高度的危险和危急时刻，在我们在乌克兰看到的完全不同的环境中也是如此。一种乌克兰的民族认同正在战争中形成，就像1940年至1941年的英格兰人一样，那是奥威尔写下那篇精彩散文的时期。所以你显然认为存在一个英格兰。我是说，你的书全讲的是这个。但英格兰性，比方说30或40年前，没有人写过英格兰或英格兰性。我的意思是，这是一个根本从未被提出过的问题，对吧？
Yes, I think there's been a kind of rear-waking of Englishness or a sense of English national identity. And it's intensified since 1997 and the election of Blair and the devolution reforms and the creation of the Scottish Parliament, when you've also had a simultaneous awakening of Scottish national identity. election of Blair and the devolution reforms and the creation of the Scottish Parliament, when you've also had a simultaneous awakening of Scottish national identity. So as the Scots have become more confident or more assertive in their sense of Scottishness and their sense of national identity, it's naturally forced upon the English a reconsideration of who they are and what they want, particularly as the United Kingdom itself is in danger. I mean, it's fragmented.
Yes, I think there's been a kind of rear-waking of Englishness or a sense of English national identity. And it's intensified since 1997 and the election of Blair and the devolution reforms and the creation of the Scottish Parliament, when you've also had a simultaneous awakening of Scottish national identity. election of Blair and the devolution reforms and the creation of the Scottish Parliament, when you've also had a simultaneous awakening of Scottish national identity. So as the Scots have become more confident or more assertive in their sense of Scottishness and their sense of national identity, it's naturally forced upon the English a reconsideration of who they are and what they want, particularly as the United Kingdom itself is in danger. I mean, it's fragmented.|||是的，我认为英格兰性或英格兰民族认同感经历了一种重新觉醒。自1997年布莱尔当选、权力下放改革以及苏格兰议会的建立以来，这种趋势愈演愈烈，当时苏格兰的民族认同也同时觉醒。布莱尔的当选、权力下放改革以及苏格兰议会的建立，当时苏格兰的民族认同也同时觉醒。因此，随着苏格兰人在其苏格兰身份和民族认同感方面变得更加自信或更加坚定，这自然迫使英格兰人重新审视他们是谁、他们想要什么，尤其是当联合王国本身处于危险之中时。我是说，它已经碎片化了。
And we had a referendum in 2014, which could have ended the union. And Nicola Sturgeon and the SNP, a powerful hegemonic, you would say, in Scotland, and obviously want a second referendum. So again, it's different from Orwell in 1940, but there is also a sense of threat to Britishness, British identity and the Union.
And we had a referendum in 2014, which could have ended the union. And Nicola Sturgeon and the SNP, a powerful hegemonic, you would say, in Scotland, and obviously want a second referendum. So again, it's different from Orwell in 1940, but there is also a sense of threat to Britishness, British identity and the Union.|||我们在2014年举行了一场公投，本可能终结这个联邦。妮古拉·斯特金和苏格兰民族党（SNP）——可以说在苏格兰拥有强大的霸权地位——显然希望进行第二次公投。所以再次说明，这与1940年的奥威尔不同，但英国性、英国认同以及联邦也面临着一种威胁感。
And it's been a period of enormous change and convulsion in recent years. I mean, if you just have to think about the last sort of seven or eight years with the Scottish independence referendum, the 2015 surprise victory for David Cameron, which then led to the 2016 Brexit referendum, the eruption of Corbynism from the left, Trump in America, and so it goes on. And meanwhile, you had this sense of kind of national populism rising through the influence of Nigel Farage and UKIP. So it's been a period of extraordinary change and convulsion and upheaval. And somewhere amidst this is a rising sense of English identity, often identified, I think, unfairly with reaction and loss and nostalgia. But I think one could make the case for a progressive and positive
And it's been a period of enormous change and convulsion in recent years. I mean, if you just have to think about the last sort of seven or eight years with the Scottish independence referendum, the 2015 surprise victory for David Cameron, which then led to the 2016 Brexit referendum, the eruption of Corbynism from the left, Trump in America, and so on. And meanwhile, you had this sense of kind of national populism rising through the influence of Nigel Farage and UKIP. So it's been a period of extraordinary change and convulsion and upheaval. And somewhere amidst this is a rising sense of English identity, often identified, I think, unfairly with reaction and loss and nostalgia. But I think one could make the case for a progressive and positive|||近年是一个经历巨大变革与动荡的时期。我是说，如果你回想过去大约七八年里发生的苏格兰独立公投、大卫·卡梅伦在2015年的意外获胜，随后引发了2016年的脱欧公投、左翼科尔宾主义的爆发、美国的特朗普等等。与此同时，由于奈杰尔·法拉奇和英国独立党（UKIP）的影响，这种国家民粹主义也在不断抬头。因此，这是一个充满非凡变革、动荡和剧变的时期。在这其中某个地方，英格兰认同感正在上升，我认为它常常被不公平地与反动、失落和怀旧划上等号。但我认为人们完全可以为一种进步和积极的——
sense of modern English identity as well within the greater framework of Britishness. Can I ask a quick question about the loss and nostalgia? Yes. Because in your introduction, you say one of the things you want to talk about in your book is the stubborn notion that Englishness and loss are inextricable. And there is something unusual about Englishness and nostalgia, isn't there? I mean, even when Orwell was writing in 1940, a lot of the things he's talking about, the sort of the rattle of pin tables in the pubs, the old maids, they were old fashioned even in 1940. And there is always this sense with Englishness, particularly now, actually, when people talk about Englishness, they talk about it in terms of it being reactionary, backward.
sense of modern English identity as well within the greater framework of Britishness. Can I ask a quick question about the loss and nostalgia? Yes. Because in your introduction, you say one of the things you want to talk about in your book is the stubborn notion that Englishness and loss are inextricable. And there is something unusual about Englishness and nostalgia, isn't there? I mean, even when Orwell was writing in 1940, a lot of the things he's talking about, the sort of the rattle of pin tables in the pubs, the old maids, they were old fashioned even in 1940. And there is always this sense with Englishness, particularly now, actually, when people talk about Englishness, they talk about it in terms of it being reactionary, backward.|||现代英格兰认同感进行辩护，它同样存在于更大的英国性框架之内。我能快速问一个关于失落和怀旧的问题吗？可以。因为在你的导言中，你说你想在书中讨论的事情之一，就是那种认为英格兰性与失落密不可分的顽固观念。关于英格兰性和怀旧，有一种很不寻常的地方，不是吗？我是说，甚至当奥威尔在1940年写作时，他谈到的许多事情——比如酒吧里弹珠台的碰撞声、老处女们——即使在1940年也已经是老式过时的了。而且关于英格兰性总是存在这样一种感觉，特别是现在，实际上，当人们谈论英格兰性时，他们会从它是反动的、落后的角度来谈论它。
I mean, you mentioned Nigel Farage. He's often seen as a kind of, as an avatar of a kind of Englishness. But do you think that's, we've got the wrong idea that there is another or well with all these things it's so hard to pin down aren't they go on tom sorry well i was i was going to say about that that one of the reasons perhaps for that is that england is as a political entity incredibly old i mean it's a very you know as a as a i mean could one say nation state i mean it as a political, it is very, very precocious. Probably Denmark is its only rival. I was about to say, some historians would say England and Denmark are the first two nation states, wouldn't they? And so you think people are always looking back to the past and saying things were better in the past.
I mean, you mentioned Nigel Farage. He's often seen as a kind of, as an avatar of a kind of Englishness. But do you think that's, we've got the wrong idea that there is another or well with all these things it's so hard to pin down aren't they go on tom sorry well i was i was going to say about that that one of the reasons perhaps for that is that england is as a political entity incredibly old i mean it's a very you know as a as a i mean could one say nation state i mean it as a political, it is very, very precocious. Probably Denmark is its only rival. I was about to say, some historians would say England and Denmark are the first two nation states, wouldn't they? And so you think people are always looking back to the past and saying things were better in the past.|||我是说，你提到了奈杰尔·法拉奇。他经常被视为某种英格兰性的化身。但你认为那是——我们是不是对这种现象产生了错误的理解，还有另一个……奥威尔曾说过，所有这些事情都如此难以捉摸，不是吗？说吧，汤姆，对不起。嗯，我本来想说的是，其中一个原因可能在于，英格兰作为一个政治实体实在是太古老了。我是说，它非常……你知道，作为一个——作为一个……我是说，能被称为民族国家吗？我的意思是，作为一个政治实体，它非常非常早熟。大概丹麦是它唯一的竞争对手。我正要说，一些历史学家会说英格兰和丹麦是最初的两个民族国家，不是吗？所以你认为人们总是回头看过去，并说过去的事情更好。
So we've done a lot of stuff on the civil wars and people in the civil war are looking back to the Anglo-Saxons and saying, well, they were free then. You know, and then the Normans imposed a yoke. If only we could get back to the glory days of the Anglo-Saxons. And that basically is a trend that, you know, or John of Gaunt's great speech. I mean, you name the passage of Orwell as one of the great meditations on England, but John of Gaunt's speech in Richard II, Shakespeare's play, where he, again, you know, he's, you know, this wonderful kind of lyrical description of England, bound in by the triumphant sea. And yet there, John of Gaunt again is mourning what he sees as English decline. So it could be that, you know, one of the most traditionally English things
So we've done a lot of stuff on the civil wars and people in the civil war are looking back to the Anglo-Saxons and saying, well, they were free then. You know, and then the Normans imposed a yoke. If only we could get back to the glory days of the Anglo-Saxons. And that basically is a trend that, you0 know, or John of Gaunt's great speech. I mean, you name the passage of Orwell as one of the great meditations on England, but John of Gaunt's speech in Richard II, Shakespeare's play, where he, again, you know, he's, you know, this wonderful kind of lyrical description of England, bound in by the triumphant sea. And yet there, John of Gaunt again is mourning what he sees as English decline. So it could be that, you know, one of the most traditionally English things|||所以我们做过很多关于内战的内容，内战中的人们会回顾盎格鲁-萨克逊人，然后说：“看，那时他们是自由的。”你知道，然后诺曼人强加了枷锁。如果我们能回到盎格鲁-萨克逊人的辉煌岁月就好了。这基本上是一个趋势，你知道的，或者像冈特的约翰（John of Gaunt）伟大的演讲。我是说，你把奥威尔的那段话列为对英格兰伟大的沉思之一，但在莎士比亚的戏剧《理查二世》中冈特的约翰的演讲里，他又一次，你知道的，他——你知道的，对英格兰进行了这种奇妙的抒情描述，被凯旋的大海所环绕。然而在那里，冈特的约翰再次哀悼他所看到的英格兰的衰落。所以这可能意味着，你知道，最具有英格兰传统的事情之一
is to worry that England is going to the dogs. That is built in. What do you think, Jason? I agree with Tom. I think I say in the book that there's this sense of something lost or something deeper and purer and more innocent that's been lost flows through the English centuries like an underground stream. And I think it does. And it's there in Shakespeare, Tom, for sure. More recently, it was there in Haussmann and his wonderful poems. It's there in English poetry. And it goes right back. I mean, I listened some weeks ago to your episode on the Norman conquest and the defeat, the sense of Englishness being founded upon a heroic defeat against the Norman invaders. But even, and then, you know, what was lost then? What was lost before the conquest going back to an Anglo-Saxon England?
is to worry that England is going to the dogs. That is built in. What do you think, Jason? I agree with Tom. I think I say in the book that there's this sense of something lost or something deeper and purer and more innocent that's been lost flows through the English centuries like an underground stream. And I think it does. And it's there in Shakespeare, Tom, for sure. More recently, it was there in Haussmann and his wonderful poems. It's there in English poetry. And it goes right back. I mean, I listened some weeks ago to your episode on the Norman conquest and the defeat, the sense of Englishness being founded upon a heroic defeat against the Norman invaders. But even, and then, you know, what was lost then? What was lost before the conquest going back to an Anglo-Saxon England?|||就是担心英格兰正在走向毁灭。这是根深蒂固的。你觉得呢，杰森？我同意汤姆的看法。我想我在书中说过，这种失去了什么东西的感觉，或者某种更深沉、更纯洁、更清白且已经失落的东西，像地下暗流一样流淌在英格兰的几个世纪中。我认为确实如此。而且它肯定存在于莎士比亚的作品中，汤姆。更近一点，它存在于豪斯曼（A. E. Housman）和他美妙的诗歌中。它存在于英格兰诗歌中。而且它可以追溯到很久以前。我是说，几个星期前我听了你们关于诺曼征服和失败的那期节目，那种将英格兰性建立在对诺曼入侵者的英雄式失败之上的感觉。但是甚至，然后，你知道，那时失去了什么？在征服之前，追溯到盎格鲁-萨克逊时期的英格兰，失去了什么？
A sense after the conquest that here was an elite that spoke French and the ordinary English man and woman, you know, the elites didn't even speak the language that they spoke themselves. So I think it's there, a sense of loss, a sense of nostalgia. And then, of course, after the Act of Union, 1707, Englishness was lost within Britishness. And the English were encouraged to see themselves, first and foremost, as British in this great imperial project
A sense after the conquest that here was an elite that spoke French and the ordinary English man and woman, you know, the elites didn't even speak the language that they spoke themselves. So I think it's there, a sense of loss, a sense of nostalgia. And then, of course, after the Act of Union, 1707, Englishness was lost within Britishness. And the English were encouraged to see themselves, first and foremost, as British in this great imperial project|||征服之后的一种感觉是，这里有一个说法语的精英阶层，而普通的英格兰男女，你知道的，精英阶层甚至不说他们自己说的那种语言。所以我认为这种感觉是存在的，一种失落感，一种怀旧感。然后，当然，在1707年《联合法案》之后，英格兰性在大不列颠性中迷失了。英格兰人被鼓励在伟大的帝国宏图中，首先也是最重要的是将自己视为英国人——
in which the English played their role, as indeed did the Scots. So Dominic's right when he said at the beginning that, you know, here's this nation, but it doesn't have its own discrete political institutions. And therefore, England in recent times hasn't been given the opportunity to reimagine itself, as indeed Scotland has through the creation of the Scottish Parliament and all of the conversation and debate that has been generated by devolution and what's followed from that. I mean, if you remember George Robertson, the Labour MP, later head of NATO, said that devolution would kill Scottish nationalism stone dead, I think was the phrase he used. Well, that didn't turn out as he hoped. But Jason, this idea that the English perhaps have of themselves as a people who are put
in which the English played their role, as indeed did the Scots. So Dominic's right when he said at the beginning that, you0 know, here's this nation, but it doesn't have its own discrete political institutions. And therefore, England in recent times hasn't been given the opportunity to reimagine itself, as indeed Scotland has through the creation of the Scottish Parliament and all of the conversation and debate that has been generated by devolution and what's followed from that. I mean, if you remember George Robertson, the Labour MP, later head of NATO, said that devolution would kill Scottish nationalism stone dead, I think was the phrase he used. Well, that didn't turn out as he hoped. But Jason, this idea that the English perhaps have of themselves as a people who are put|||英格兰人在其中发挥了他们的作用，苏格兰人也确实如此。所以多米尼克在开头说得对，你知道的，这是一个国家，但它没有自己独立的政治机构。因此，近年来英格兰没有获得重新想象自己的机会，正如苏格兰通过建立苏格兰议会以及权力下放及其后续引发的所有对话和辩论所做的那样。我是说，如果你还记得工党议员、后来的北约负责人乔治·罗伯逊（George Robertson）曾说过，权力下放将彻底扼杀苏格兰民族主义，我想这是他用的词。好吧，结果并没有像他希望的那样。但是杰森，英格兰人或许认为自己是一个饱受欺凌的民族的这种想法——
upon, who have reasons to feel that things have been lost, and Orwell describes them as a gentle people. I imagine that there'll be lots of people listening to this outside England who may feel that this characterisation is perhaps not entirely accurate. I mean, i would imagine within uh within great britain and and certainly within ireland as well the idea that the english are you know are put upon a nation of flower rangers cycling yes exactly and of course you know england was the most powerful component of the country that established the largest empire in world history.
upon, who have reasons to feel that things have been lost, and Orwell describes them as a gentle people. I imagine that there'll be lots of people listening to this outside England who may feel that this characterisation is perhaps not entirely accurate. I mean, i would imagine within uh within great britain and and certainly within ireland as well the idea that the english are you know are put upon a nation of flower rangers cycling yes exactly and of course you know england was the most powerful component of the country that established the largest empire in world history.|||有理由感到某些东西已经失去，而奥威尔将他们描述为一个温和的民族。我想在英格兰以外收听这个节目的人中，会有很多人觉得这种描述可能并不完全准确。我的意思是，我可以想象在呃——在大不列颠境内，当然也在爱尔兰境内，认为英格兰人是——你知道的——受欺负的人、一个骑自行车赏花的民族，是的，完全如此。当然，你知道，英格兰是建立世界历史上最大帝国的那个国家中最强大的组成部分。
And the English were not gentle in the Caribbean. They were often not gentle in India. Orwell himself, of course, he was a policeman in Burma, absolutely knew that. There is a sense, isn't there, that Englishness is complicated by the legacy of that, not least because large numbers of people from that empire have now come to England. Yes, and that's, I don't think I said the English were gentle. No, Orwell did. And I think there is this idea still people have that the English are a uniquely kind of gentle people. Absolutely. When you watch something like the Antiques Roadshow on a Sunday evening on the BBC, I mean, there's a vision of England that many people wish to identify with.
And the English were not gentle in the Caribbean. They were often not gentle in India. Orwell himself, of course, he was a policeman in Burma, absolutely knew that. There is a sense, isn't there, that Englishness is complicated by the legacy of that, not least because large numbers of people from that empire have now come to England. Yes, and that's, I don't think I said the English were gentle. No, Orwell did. And I think there is this idea still people have that the English are a uniquely kind of gentle people. Absolutely. When you watch something like the Antiques Roadshow on a Sunday evening on the BBC, I mean, there's a vision of England that many people wish to identify with.|||英格兰人在加勒比海并不温和。他们在印度也常常并不温和。奥威尔本人当然在缅甸当过警察，对此绝对心知肚明。有一种感觉，不是吗？英格兰性因这段历史的遗产而变得复杂，尤其是因为来自那个帝国的大量人口现在已经来到了英格兰。是的，那是——我不认为我说过英格兰人很温和。不，是奥威尔说的。而且我认为人们仍然有一种看法，即英格兰人是一个极其温和的民族。完全如此。当你在周日晚上收看BBC的《古董巡回秀》（Antiques Roadshow）之类的节目时，我的意思是，那里有一种许多人希望认同的英格兰愿景。
But of course, go to Newcastle City Centre on a Saturday night and you see a completely different England. Or, you know, I spent a lot of time on the football terraces over the years, as has Dominic. And certainly the England I witnessed in the late 70s and into the early 80s was brutal and violent. And there was an association with the violence in wider society, what one saw on the terraces. Orwell also said that he likened the English to a family with the wrong people in charge, in control. So again, he was deeply critical of the empire. And that's one of the challenges for anyone writing about Englishness today is this contested identity and also the past, empire, slavery, colonialism, the tensions within the British state itself, Ireland, the Irish question, and so on. So I think for those on the left or many on the left, they view Englishness with deep suspicion. And there's often, as I said at the beginning, associated with reaction, even racism. I mean, the internationalist left are
But of course, go to Newcastle City Centre on a Saturday night and you see a completely different England. Or, you know, I spent a lot of time on the football terraces over the years, as has Dominic. And certainly the England I witnessed in the late 70s and into the early 80s was brutal and violent. And there was an association with the violence in wider society, what one saw on the terraces. Orwell also said that he likened the English to a family with the wrong people in charge, in control. So again, he was deeply critical of the empire. And that's one of the challenges for anyone writing about Englishness today is this contested identity and also the past, empire, slavery, colonialism, the tensions within the British state itself, Ireland, the Irish question, and so on. So I think for those on the left or many on the left, they view Englishness with deep suspicion. And there's often, as I said at the beginning, associated with reaction, even racism. I mean, the internationalist left are|||但当然，去周六晚上的纽卡斯尔市中心，你会看到一个完全不同的英格兰。或者，你知道的，这些年来我在足球看台上度过了很多时间，多米尼克也是如此。当然，我在70年代末到80年代初见证的英格兰是残酷而暴力的。这种暴力与更广泛社会中的暴力息息相关，正如人们在看台上所看到的那样。奥威尔还说过，他把英格兰比作一个由错误的人掌权、控制的家庭。因此，他再次对帝国进行了深刻的批判。这也是今天任何撰写关于英格兰性文章的人所面临的挑战之一：这种备受争议的认同感，以及过去、帝国、奴隶制、殖民主义、英国国家内部的紧张关系、爱尔兰、爱尔兰问题等等。所以我认为对于左翼人士或许多左翼人士来说，他们对英格兰性抱有深深的怀疑。而且正如我开头所说，它经常与反动甚至种族主义联系在一起。我是说，国际主义左翼是——
all for celebrating the statehood of others, the Palestinians or the Kurds. But when it comes to English national identity, they're very, very suspicious. And it alarms them. I think that's fair to say, Dominic, would you? I definitely think it. I mean, Orwell commented on that, didn't he? I can't remember whether it was in this essay, in The Lion and the Unicorn, or whether it was in The Road to Wigan Pier, where he talks about intellectuals
all for celebrating the statehood of others, the Palestinians or the Kurds. But when it comes to English national identity, they're very, very suspicious. And it alarms them. I think that's fair to say, Dominic, would you? I definitely think it. I mean, Orwell commented on that, didn't I? I can't remember whether it was in this essay, in The Lion and the Unicorn, or whether it was in The Road to Wigan Pier, where he talks about intellectuals|||全力庆祝其他人的国家地位，比如巴勒斯坦人或库尔德人。但当谈到英格兰的民族认同感时，他们非常非常怀疑。这让他们感到警惕。我认为这样说很公平，多米尼克，你觉得呢？我绝对这么认为。我是说，奥威尔对此发表过评论，不是吗？我不记得是在这篇散文《狮子与独角兽》中，还是在《通往威根码头之路》（The Road to Wigan Pier）中，他谈到了知识分子——
who would rather be seen stealing from a poor box in church than standing for God save the king. And I think that element has always been there. Not always, surely. I mean, it's there, isn't it, in the French Revolutionary period? I mean, that's probably where it first starts to appear. The sort of Tom Paine-ish element that England is. Yeah, but the Whigs.
who would rather be seen stealing from a poor box in church than standing for God save the king. And I think that element has always been there. Not always, surely. I mean, it's there, isn't it, in the French Revolutionary period? I mean, that's probably where it first starts to appear. The sort of Tom Paine-ish element that England is. Yeah, but the Whigs.|||宁愿被人看到在教堂的穷人捐款箱里偷东西，也不愿起立高唱《天佑吾王》。我认为这种成分一直都存在。并非一直如此吧。我是说，在法国大革命时期它就存在，不是吗？我是说，那可能就是它最初开始出现的地方。那种托马斯·佩恩式的英格兰成分。是的，但是辉格党人——
So Fox, you know, basically saying the French Revolution's brilliant and Napoleon's brilliant. And essentially it's not really about Napoleon's French Revolution. It's about his dislike of aspects of Tory England. Yeah, but there is a strain within Englishness. I mean, I don't think other countries have it. I mean, there is a strain in America that thinks that about people who are very anti-American Americans. But I think England is probably unusual in having such a profoundly developed sense of anti-patriotism.
So Fox, you know, basically saying the French Revolution's brilliant and Napoleon's brilliant. And essentially it's not really about Napoleon's French Revolution. It's about his dislike of aspects of Tory England. Yeah, but there is a strain within Englishness. I mean, I don't think other countries have it. I mean, there is a strain in America that thinks that about people who are very anti-American Americans. But I think England is probably unusual in having such a profoundly developed sense of anti-patriotism.|||所以查尔斯·詹姆斯·福克斯（Fox），你知道的，基本上说法国大革命太棒了，拿破仑太棒了。本质上，这其实并不是关于拿破仑的法国大革命。而是关于他不喜欢保守党英格兰的某些方面。是的，但英格兰性中确实存在这样一种倾向。我是说，我不认为其他国家有这种倾向。我是说，美国有一种倾向，认为那些极端反美的美国人有这种想法。但我认为英格兰的独特之处在于，它拥有如此深刻发展的反爱国主义意识。
And why do you think that is i don't i mean it's a massive question i mean tom you'll be delighted to hear i think part of it is religious isn't it i mean it's sort of rooted in the isn't it rooted in the kind of dissenting whiggish kind of tradition i think um and it's obviously also a day you think jason a reaction to empire in the 19th century and it's? And the empire obviously looms enormously large in the mindsets of sort of left-wing English or British intellectuals today, doesn't it? Absolutely. And when you listen to or even participate in the debates about Englishness and empire, particularly intensification in recent years, there's almost a sense of shame at times about the pressure of imperial history
And why do you think that is i don't i mean it's a massive question i mean tom you'll be delighted to hear i think part of it is religious isn't it i mean it's sort of rooted in the isn't it rooted in the kind of dissenting whiggish kind of tradition i think um and it's obviously also a day you think jason a reaction to empire in the 19th century and it's? And the empire obviously looms enormously large in the mindsets of sort of left-wing English or British intellectuals today, doesn't it? Absolutely. And when you listen to or even participate in the debates about Englishness and empire, particularly intensification in recent years, there's almost a sense of shame at times about the pressure of imperial history|||你认为这是为什么？我不知道——我是说这是一个宏大的问题。汤姆，你听到这里一定会很高兴，我认为部分原因在于宗教，不是吗？我的意思是，它某种程度上植根于——难道不是植根于那种异议的辉格党传统吗？我认为，嗯，显然这也是——你认为杰森，这是对19世纪帝国的反弹吗？而且帝国显然在当今左翼英格兰或英国知识分子的思维方式中占据了极其巨大的比重，不是吗？绝对是的。当你倾听甚至参与关于英格兰性和帝国的辩论时，特别是近年来这种辩论愈演愈烈，有时几乎会产生一种因帝国历史的压力而带来的羞耻感。
weighing on the present. But also I think it's, I go back to the point that it's also a sense of Englishness being lost within Britishness. And there's always a worry about national identity, about ethnicity and blood and soil, certainly. And one of the glories of Britishness, I think, is that it was a non-racial, inclusive, plural identity.
weighing on the present. But also I think it's, I go back to the point that it's also a sense of Englishness being lost within Britishness. And there's always a worry about national identity, about ethnicity and blood and soil, certainly. And one of the glories of Britishness, I think, is that it was a non-racial, inclusive, plural identity.|||这种压力压在当下。但我也认为，我还是要回到那个观点，即这也是英格兰性在大不列颠性中迷失的一种感觉。人们总是对民族认同、对种族以及血缘与土地感到担忧，这是肯定的。我认为，英国性（Britishness）的光荣之一在于，它是一种非种族的、包容的、多元的认同。
We sheltered under this civic umbrella, if that's not a mixed metaphor, of Britishness. And I would argue, perhaps better than any other European country, the British have welcomed migrants since the Second World War. I know there's been terrible racism and hostility, but the modern British state is pretty harmonious, particularly when you compare it with France, with a distinct neo-fascist right. We haven't had the emergence of a neo-fascist right in this country. But Jason, isn't there a kind of paradox there, perhaps, that since 97, certainly, the rate of immigration into Britain has massively increased, and obviously not just from Commonwealth countries, but from the European Union. And so the proportion of foreign-born children in England has gone up massively. And so you would think that in that period, the salience of Britishness would be all the more important if it is. And I agree with you that it's something that kind of transcends
We sheltered under this civic umbrella, if that's not a mixed metaphor, of Britishness. And I would argue, perhaps better than any other European country, the British have welcomed migrants since the Second World War. I know there's been terrible racism and hostility, but the modern British state is pretty harmonious, particularly when you compare it with France, with a distinct neo-fascist right. We haven't had the emergence of a neo-fascist right in this country. But Jason, isn't there a kind of paradox there, perhaps, that since 97, certainly, the rate of immigration into Britain has massively increased, and obviously not just from Commonwealth countries, but from the European Union. And so the proportion of foreign-born children in England has gone up massively. And so you would think that in that period, the salience of Britishness would be all the more important if it is. And I agree with you that it's something that kind of transcends|||我们在英国性这个公民雨伞下寻求庇护——如果这个比喻不算混杂的话。我要说的是，也许比其他任何欧洲国家都做得更好，英国自第二次世界大战以来一直欢迎移民。我知道这里曾存在可怕的种族主义和敌意，但现代英国国家相当和谐，特别是当你把它与有着鲜清新法西斯右翼的法国相比时。我们这个国家并没有出现新法西斯右翼。但是杰森，这其中难道没有某种悖论吗？自1997年以来，进入英国的移民比率肯定大幅增加，显然不仅来自英联邦国家，还来自欧盟。因此，英格兰外国出生儿童的比例大幅上升。所以你会认为，在那个时期，英国性的显赫地位将变得更加重要（如果确实如此的话）。而且我同意你的观点，即它是一种某种程度上超越了……
the idea of ancient national roots far more than Englishness or Scottishness or Welshness does. And yet it's precisely the more that immigration has gone up, the more the sense of people being English or indeed Scottish has gone up as well. I mean, do you think it's a kind of degree of cause and effect there? I think there is. There's a chapter about the cockle picking disaster on Morecambe Bay 2004, but within that chapter, I write- So that's when the Chinese laborers were drowned. Yeah, the undocumented Chinese migrants who were working as cockle-pickers. And I tell the story of the lone survivor of that disaster.
the idea of ancient national roots far more than Englishness or Scottishness or Welshness does. And yet it's precisely the more that immigration has gone up, the more the sense of people being English or indeed Scottish has gone up as well. I mean, do you think it's a kind of degree of cause and effect there? I think there is. There's a chapter about the cockle picking disaster on Morecambe Bay 2004, but within that chapter, I write- So that's when the Chinese laborers were drowned. Yeah, the undocumented Chinese migrants who were working as cockle-pickers. And I tell the story of the lone survivor of that disaster.|||古代民族根源的概念的因素，远远超过了英格兰性、苏格兰性或威尔士性所能做到的。然而，恰恰是随着移民数量的增加，人们觉得自己是英格兰人——或者确实是苏格兰人——的意识也在不断增强。我是说，你认为这其中是否存在某种程度的因果关系？我认为是有的。书中有一章关于2004年莫克姆湾（Morecambe Bay）拾贝悲剧的内容，但在那一章里，我写到——那正是中国劳工溺水身亡的时候。是的，那些作为拾贝工工作的无证中国移民。我讲述了那场灾难中唯一的幸存者的故事。
But it happened in 2004. And that was also the year when the EU enlarged and opened up to the Eastern states. And I was talking to Nigel Farage about this, because Farage is a figure in the book, inevitably, because he's been such an influential politician, you know, one of the most influential post-war politicians. And he said to me that immigration and the EU, they were not an issue until 2004. And then he saw his opportunity to reopen the immigration debate,
But it happened in 2004. And that was also the year when the EU enlarged and opened up to the Eastern states. And I was talking to Nigel Farage about this, because Farage is a figure in the book, inevitably, because he's been such an influential politician, you know, one of the most influential post-war politicians. And he said to me that immigration and the EU, they were not an issue until 2004. And then he saw his opportunity to reopen the immigration debate,|||但那是发生在2004年。那也是欧盟扩大并向东欧国家开放的一年。我曾就此与奈杰尔·法拉奇交谈过，因为法拉奇不可避免地是书中的一个人物，因为他曾是一位极具影响力的政治家，你知道的，是战后最有影响力的政治家之一。他对我坦言，移民和欧盟在2004年之前并不是一个问题。然后他看到了重新开启移民辩论的机会，
which he said had been closed down ever since Enoch Powell had delivered his rivers of blood speech. When was it, Dominic? End of the 60s? 68. 68, that was. So he suddenly saw an opportunity and he said he was warned by fellow big figures within UKIP not to go there. This would be too dangerous. But he said it was never about, for him,
which he said had been closed down ever since Enoch Powell had delivered his rivers of blood speech. When was it, Dominic? End of the 60s? 68. 68, that was. So he suddenly saw an opportunity and he said he was warned by fellow big figures within UKIP not to go there. This would be too dangerous. But he said it was never about, for him,|||他指出，自从伊诺克·鲍威尔（Enoch Powell）发表臭名昭著的“血河”演讲以来，这个问题就一直被搁置。那是什么时候，多米尼克？60年代末？68年。是的，那是1968年。所以他突然看到了一个机会，并表示英国独立党（UKIP）内的其他大佬曾警告他不要碰这个话题。这会太危险了。但他表示，对他来说，这绝不是关于——
it was never about ethnicity or race. It was about numbers and a loss of control. And he was able to manipulate that. And don't forget, of the EU member states, it was only the UK, Sweden, and Ireland that neglected to impose seven-year transition controls. So Germany, France, Italy, the other big economies, chose to impose the seven-year control.
it was never about ethnicity or race. It was about numbers and a loss of control. And he was able to manipulate that. And don't forget, of the EU member states, it was only the UK, Sweden, and Ireland that neglected to impose seven-year transition controls. So Germany, France, Italy, the other big economies, chose to impose the seven-year control.|||这从来都不是关于种族或民族的。这是关于人数和失控的问题。他能够操纵这一点。别忘了，在欧盟成员国中，只有英国、瑞典和爱尔兰没有实施为期七年的过渡期管制。因此，德国、France、意大利等其他主要经济体都选择实施了这七年的管制。
So they wouldn't accept migrants from the East under free movement rules for seven years. And the Labour government at the time, the very complacent new Labour governments, said they expected around 8,000 to 13,000 migrants from the eastern states to arrive per year. Yeah, and the true figure was? Hundreds and hundreds of thousands. But what it was, Tom, was the largest unplanned migration, surely, in British history.
So they wouldn't accept migrants from the East under free movement rules for seven years. And the Labour government at the time, the very complacent new Labour governments, said they expected around 8,000 to 13,000 migrants from the eastern states to arrive per year. Yeah, and the true figure was? Hundreds and hundreds of thousands. But what it was, Tom, was the largest unplanned migration, surely, in British history.|||所以他们在七年内不会根据自由流动规则接受来自东欧的移民. 当时的工党政府，那个非常自满的新工党政府，声称他们预计每年会有大约8,000到13,000名来自东欧国家的移民到来。是的，而真实数字是多少？数十万之多。但汤姆，这绝对是英国历史上规模最大的一次非计划性移民。
Absolutely. But it still doesn't answer the question of why that hasn't amplified people's sense of identity as British, rather than, say, English. Because simultaneously, you've had the devolution reforms. So when Blair came to power, he gave a speech before he came to power in 1995, where he said, I want this to be a young country. And then he said, we will be a young country. He never spoke about England. He was speaking about Britain. I mean, what an absurd thing to say, Tom. You've spoken already about the deep history of England and the notion of an English nation. And Blair wanted us to be part of a young country. In other words, he wanted to will a new country into being and push back against the burdens of the past as he would have seen them. And he thought one way of becoming a young country would be through the devolution reforms. But they ignited Scottish nationalism. Is that, do you think, because...
Absolutely. But it still doesn't answer the question of why that hasn't amplified people's sense of identity as British, rather than, say, English. Because simultaneously, you've had the devolution reforms. So when Blair came to power, he gave a speech before he came to power in 1995, where he said, I want this to be a young country. And then he said, we will be a young country. He never spoke about England. He was speaking about Britain. I mean, what an absurd thing to say, Tom. You've spoken already about the deep history of England and the notion of an English nation. And Blair wanted us to be part of a young country. In other words, he wanted to will a new country into being and push back against the burdens of the past as he would have seen them. And he thought one way of becoming a young country would be through the devolution reforms. But they ignited Scottish nationalism. Is that, do you think, because...|||完全正确。但这仍然没有回答这个问题：为什么这没有增强人们对英国人身份的认同感，而不是对英格兰人身份的认同感？因为与此同时，你们进行了权力下放改革。因此，当布莱尔上台时，他在1995年上台前发表了一次演讲，其中他说：“我希望这是一个年轻的国家。”然后他说：“我们将成为一个年轻的国家。”他从未谈论过英格兰。他谈论的是英国。我是说，汤姆，这是多么荒谬的话。你之前已经谈过了英格兰深厚的历史和英格兰民族的概念。而布莱尔希望我们成为一个年轻国家的一部分。换句话说，他想用意志催生出一个新国家，并摆脱他所认为的过去历史的包袱。他认为成为年轻国家的一种途径是通过权力下放改革。但它们点燃了苏格兰民族主义。你认为这是因为……
They fired Scottish nationalism. Jason, he didn't understand. My take on that would be that he just, because he didn't feel it himself, he simply didn't understand the cultural and political power of nationalism. So it almost didn't occur to him that by creating a Scottish Parliament or a Welsh Assembly, you would create a vessel into which people would pour all these energies which had lain dormant for so long. Do you think he just didn't get that? I think that's right. And also what he didn't understand was there was a restiveness out there in what you might call deep England, in the shires, the smaller county towns and neglected coastal towns, the town I grew up in, Harlow Newtown, for example, where people felt shut out. They felt neglected. They felt ignored. They felt mocked and ridiculed by a certain kind of elite. And they were anxious about the forces unleashed by free market globalization,
They fired Scottish nationalism. Jason, he didn't understand. My take on that would be that he just, because he didn't feel it himself, he simply didn't understand the cultural and political power of nationalism. So it almost didn't occur to him that by creating a Scottish Parliament or a Welsh Assembly, you would create a vessel into which people would pour all these energies which had lain dormant for so long. Do you think he just didn't get that? I think that's right. And also what he didn't understand was there was a restiveness out there in what you might call deep England, in the shires, the smaller county towns and neglected coastal towns, the town I grew up in, Harlow Newtown, for example, where people felt shut out. They felt neglected. They felt ignored. They felt mocked and ridiculed by a certain kind of elite. And they were anxious about the forces unleashed by free market globalization,|||它们点燃了苏格兰民族主义。杰森，他根本不理解。我对这一点的看法是，他只是因为自己没有切身体会，所以根本不理解民族主义的文化和政治力量。因此，他几乎没有想到，通过建立苏格兰议会或威尔士议会，你会创造出一个容器，人们会将所有沉寂了这么久的能量倾注其中。你觉得他就是没明白这一点吗？我想是的。而且他同样不理解的是，在你所谓的“深层英格兰”（deep England）中——在乡村、较小的郡城和被忽视的沿海城镇，比如我长大的那个小镇哈洛新城（Harlow New Town），人们感到被排斥在外。他们感到被忽视。他们感到被冷落。他们感到受到某种精英阶层的嘲弄和讥讽。他们对自由市场全球化释放出的力量感到焦虑，
inevitably. And globalization lifted hundreds of millions of people out of poverty, notably in China. And the transnational elites, they benefited enormously from globalization and indeed from free movement. But there were many losers. And many of those losers were in the small towns of England. But just to stick up for Tony. You go ahead, Tom. Okay, so the idea of England being a young country, and let's focus on England rather than Britain. We've talked about its antiquity. The sense that perhaps that foreigners have of England is indeed of ancient monuments and tradition and beef eaters and all that kind of paraphernalia. But since the Second World War, England has quite successfully reinvented itself
inevitably. And globalization lifted hundreds of millions of people out of poverty, notably in China. And the transnational elites, they benefited enormously from globalization and indeed from free movement. But there were many losers. And many of those losers were in the small towns of England. But just to stick up for Tony. You go ahead, Tom. Okay, so the idea of England being a young country, and let's focus on England rather than Britain. We've talked about its antiquity. The sense that perhaps that foreigners have of England is indeed of ancient monuments and tradition and beef eaters and all that kind of paraphernalia. But since the Second World War, England has quite successfully reinvented itself|||这是不可避免的。全球化使数以亿计的人摆脱了贫困，尤其是在中国。跨国精英们从全球化以及自由流动中获益匪浅。但也有许多失意者。而这些失意者大都住在英格兰的小镇里。不过，为了替托尼（布莱尔）说几句话……请继续，汤姆。好的，那么关于英格兰是一个年轻国家的想法，让我们把重点放在英格兰而不是英国上。我们已经讨论过它的古老历史。外国人对英格兰的印象可能确实是古迹、传统、皇家禁卫军（beef eaters）以及所有这些相关的琐碎事物。但自二战以来，英格兰非常成功地重塑了自己——
as a young country to the degree that it is probably, head for head, the most influential proponent of youth culture in the world. Swinging London, punk, raves, all that kind of malarkey. You sound like a high court judge, Tom. I know. But it's all been part of the English brand. And you could say that in a sense, London, for instance, which is the English capital. And you could say that in a sense, London, for instance, which is the English capital, as well as the British capital, is definitely a young city, or it has seen itself as being a young city. But London doesn't feel like an English. I mean, I don't want to sound Farageist, but I don't want to sound Farageist. London feels British,
as a young country to the degree that it is probably, head for head, the most influential proponent of youth culture in the world. Swinging London, punk, raves, all that kind of malarkey. You sound like a high court judge, Tom. I know. But it's all been part of the English brand. And you could say that in a sense, London, for instance, which is the English capital. And you could say that in a sense, London, for instance, which is the English capital, as well as the British capital, is definitely a young city, or it has seen itself as being a young city. But London doesn't feel like an English. I mean, I don't want to sound Farageist, but I don't want to sound Farageist. London feels British,|||作为一个年轻国家，其程度可以说是按人头计算全球最具影响力的青年文化的推崇者。摇摆的伦敦（Swinging London）、朋克、锐舞派对，所有这些胡闹的东西。你听起来像个高等法院法官，汤姆。我知道。但这一切都成了英格兰品牌的一部分。你可以说，在某种意义上，伦敦——例如，它是英格兰的首都。你可以说，在某种意义上，伦敦——例如，它既是英格兰的首都，也是英国的首都——绝对是一座年轻的城市，或者它一直视自己为一座年轻的城市。但伦敦感觉不像一个英格兰的城市。我是说，我不想听起来像个法拉奇主义者，但我不想显得像个法拉奇主义者。伦敦感觉很英国（British），
but I don't think you would go to London and say this feels like the England of deep England. No, of course it doesn't. Of course, by definition, because, because Longleterre Profond, you know, it's not London. I mean, that's the whole point. That's the whole point of it. But it is, I think, you know, it focuses again, this question that I'm kind of just chipping away at, which is, it does feel like a British, you know, it's the British capital. It's a British city. It's a city full of black British, Asian British, Irish British, you know, it's the British capital, it's a British city, it's a city full of Black British, Asian British, Irish British, you know, all these kind of different permutations of British you have. But it's more difficult to attach those labels to English, Black English, Asian English, Irish English. I mean, there's a kind of hint of paradox almost there. So why is it that with the
but I don't think you would go to London and say this feels like the England of deep England. No, of course it doesn't. Of course, by definition, because, because Longleterre Profond, you know, it's not London. I mean, that's the whole point. That's the whole point of it. But it is, I think, you know, it focuses again, this question that I'm kind of just chipping away at, which is, it does feel like a British, you know, it's the British capital. It's a British city. It's a city full of black British, Asian British, Irish British, you know, it's the British capital, it's a British city, it's a city full of Black British, Asian British, Irish British, you know, all these kind of different permutations of British you have. But it's more difficult to attach those labels to English, Black English, Asian English, Irish English. I mean, there's a kind of hint of paradox almost there. So why is it that with the|||但我认为你不会去伦敦，然后说这感觉就像深层英格兰的英格兰。不，当然不是。当然，按定义来说，因为……因为“法兰西深处”（Longleterre Profond）——你知道的，它不是伦敦。我的意思是，这正是关键所在。这正是问题的全部所在。但它确实是，我认为，你知道，它再次聚焦于我一直在试图剖析的这个问题，即：它确实感觉像是一个英国的……你知道，它是英国的首都。它是一座英国的城市。它是一座充满黑人英国人、亚裔英国人、爱尔兰裔英国人的城市——你知道的，它是英国的首都，它是一座英国的城市，它是一座充满黑人英国人、亚裔英国人、爱尔兰裔英国人的城市，你知道的，拥有所有这些不同变体的英国人。但要把这些标签贴在英格兰人身上要困难得多——黑人英格兰人、亚裔英格兰人、爱尔兰裔英格兰人。我的意思是，这其中几乎带有一丝悖论的意味。那么，为什么随着——
amplification of immigration, with absolutely the sense that London is now not just, you know, it's not just a British, it's not just European, it's absolutely a global city. Why has that Britishness, the quality of Britishness, slightly been occluded by the growth of Englishness? I mean, it does seem a slight paradox there. It does. But it's because so many people, I think, feel shut out from that Britishness, that sense of modern Britishness that you've rightly celebrated, Tom, you know, the modern London that you and I know and love. many of those people who were attracted by the rhetoric of Farage in particular and UKIP, they don't feel attracted by that modern, cosmopolitan, London Britishness. And nor do the Scots, actually. I remember, I can't speak for the whole of the Scots,
amplification of immigration, with absolutely the sense that London is now not just, you know, it's not just a British, it's not just European, it's absolutely a global city. Why has that Britishness, the quality of Britishness, slightly been occluded by the growth of Englishness? I mean, it does seem a slight paradox there. It does. But it's because so many people, I think, feel shut out from that Britishness, that sense of modern Britishness that you've rightly celebrated, Tom, you know, the modern London that you and I know and love. many of those people who were attracted by the rhetoric of Farage in particular and UKIP, they don't feel attracted by that modern, cosmopolitan, London Britishness. And nor do the Scots, actually. I remember, I can't speak for the whole of the Scots,|||移民的扩大，以及伦敦现在不仅是——你知道的——不仅是一个英国城市，不仅是欧洲城市，它绝对是一个全球性城市的感觉？为什么这种英国性、英国性的品质，会被英格兰性的增长所轻微掩盖呢？我的意思是，这确实看起来有点像个悖论。确实如此。但这是因为很多人，我认为，觉得自己被排斥在那种英国性之外——也就是你正确地赞美过的那种现代英国性的感觉，汤姆，你知道的，你我和谐共知并热爱的现代伦敦。许多被法拉奇和英国独立党（UKIP）的言论所吸引的人，他们对那种现代的、大都会式的、伦敦式的英国性并不感到吸引。事实上，苏格兰人也是如此。我记得——我无法代表所有苏格兰人，
but I remember Alex Salmond, I invited him to come down to London to give a lecture during the 2014 independence campaign. And he likened London to a dark star, sucking the energy forces from the rest of the United Kingdom as it draws more and more people to London. But I said, Alex, hold on here. London also has some of the most impoverished boroughs in the country. There's deep intergenerational inequality and poverty in London. It's a wonderful, diverse city. It's a city of really interconnecting villages. I mean, there is a deep history of London, Tom,
but I remember Alex Salmond, I invited him to come down to London to give a lecture during the 2014 independence campaign. And he likened London to a dark star, sucking the energy forces from the rest of the United Kingdom as it draws more and more people to London. But I said, Alex, hold on here. London also has some of the most impoverished boroughs in the country. There's deep intergenerational inequality and poverty in London. It's a wonderful, diverse city. It's a city of really interconnecting villages. I mean, there is a deep history of London, Tom,|||但我记得亚历克斯·萨尔蒙德（Alex Salmond），在2014年独立运动期间，我曾邀请他来伦敦发表演讲。他把伦敦比作一颗暗星，随着将越来越多的人吸引到伦敦，它正在吸干联合王国其余地区的能量。但我说：“亚历克斯，等等。伦敦也有国内最贫困的一些行政区。伦敦存在着深层的代际不平等和贫困。这是一座奇妙、多元的城市。这是一座由真正互联互通的村庄组成的城市。我的意思是，伦敦有着深厚的历史，汤姆，”
that you understand and well know. As you walk the streets of London, one is haunted by the ghost traces of what has been before. You know, my father came out of the East End and always used to speak very fondly about the old Jewish East End that exists almost today in ghost traces, as it were. it were wg zaybold wrote about so so beautifully i think in austerlitz um so there is a paradox and this these are the these these are the paradoxes that i'm trying to work away uh at in in the book as i try and understand you know who
你所理解和熟知的。当你走在伦敦的街头，你会为那些过往事物的幽灵痕迹而感到挥之不去。你知道，我的父亲来自东区，他过去总是非常深情地谈论那个老犹太东区，它几乎作为幽灵般的痕迹存在于今天的现实中，可以这么说。温弗里德·塞巴尔德（W.G. Sebald）在《奥斯特利茨》中写得非常非常美妙，我认为——所以这里有一个悖论，这些就是我试图在书中努力探讨的悖论，当我试图理解，你知道，我们
we are today you know what is england um and what what what these huge, huge forces have done to the country in recent times. There's a wonderful line from The Lion and the Unicorn, such a great essay if you want to think about these questions, where Orwell says it is of the deepest importance to try and determine what England is before guessing what part England can play in the huge events that are happening. And that's really the question that's informed the book and that I've attempted to answer, not with any certainty, but I play with some of these paradoxes, Tom, that you're rightly raising. Let's take a break now. And when we come back, we will play with more paradoxes. And continue. And continue our search for England. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
今天是谁，你知道英格兰是什么——以及近年来这些巨大无比的力量对这个国家做了什么。《狮子与独角兽》中有一句精彩的话，如果你想思考这些问题，这是一篇非常棒的essay，奥威尔在其中说道，在猜测英格兰能在正在发生的巨大事件中扮演什么角色之前，试着去确定英格兰是什么，这具有最深远的意义。这确实是启发了这本书并我试图去回答的问题，虽然没有绝对的把握，但我探讨了其中一些悖论，汤姆，你提出的这些正是切中要害。我们现在休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将探讨更多的悖论。并继续。并继续我们对英格兰的寻找。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. And that will be England gone. The shadows, the meadows, the lanes, the guild halls, the carved choirs. There'll be books. It will linger on in galleries. But all that remains for us will be concrete and tires. That was the ever cheerful Philip Larkin writing, I think, back in the 60s. And Jason, one of the things that strikes me about England is that the English are famously animal lovers. They love their countryside, and more people belong to wildlife support groups than in any other country in the world. And yet we have some of the most, you know, we're one of the most environmentally depleted countries anywhere. Our biodiversity is in a constant case, state of crisis. I wonder, England is actually quite
这就是 therestisentertainment.com。英格兰将就此消逝。那些阴影、草地、林荫小道、会馆、雕花的唱诗班。还会有书籍。它将流连于美术馆中。但留给我们的将只有混凝土和轮胎。以上是永远乐观的菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin）的作品，我想，那是在20世纪60年代。杰森，关于英格兰，让我感触很深的一点是，英国人出了名地喜爱动物。他们热爱乡村，加入野生动物支持组织的人数比世界上任何其他国家都多。然而我们却是一些，你知道的，我们是世界上环境遭到破坏最严重的国家之一。我们的生物多样性一直处于危机状态。我想知道，英格兰其实是一个相当
a small country. Is there a sense that the rising population in England is generating these anxieties about whether England, simply because there isn't actually that much of it, and that the more people there are, the more it will turn into concrete and tyres, and the more kind of hedgehogs and hedgerows will vanish? What is the population of England? Is it about 58 million, 57 million? The population of the UK is almost 70 million and England is by far, I mean, it's about 60 million, I would have said.
小的国家。人们是否会有一种感觉，即英格兰不断增长的人口正在引发这些焦虑：英格兰是否仅仅因为它其实并没有那么大，人越多，就越会变成混凝土和轮胎，而越多的刺猬和树篱将会消失？英格兰的人口是多少？是大约5800万、5700万吗？英国的总人口接近70万，而英格兰占了绝大部分——我的意思是，我本来会说大约是6000万。
And it is a relatively small landmass and a small country. And I think that's also one of the anxieties that drives the debate about the British Union. If Scotland was to become an independent country, then England or British, Britain would lose or England would lose access to so much of the territorial waters and the landmass.
而且它相对来说是一片小土地和一个小国家。我认为这也是推动关于英国联合（British Union）辩论的焦虑之一。如果苏格兰成为一个独立国家，那么英格兰或英国、不列颠将失去或英格兰将失去对如此之多的领海和土地的控制权。
I think Scotland's about a third of the island of Great Britain in size. But yes, Tom, I think a lot of people, I think, associate England and Englishness with landscape, particularly the countryside. Yeah, green and pleasant land. Green and pleasant land. You've got Larkin there. I mentioned Houseman's beautiful poems earlier the elegies um wordsworth the romantic tradition about
我认为苏格兰的大小约占大不列颠岛的三分之一。但是的，汤姆，我想很多人，我认为，将英格兰和英格兰特色与风景联系在一起，特别是乡村风光。是的，郁郁葱葱、令人愉悦的土地。郁郁葱葱、令人愉悦的土地。你有拉金的诗。我刚才提到了豪斯曼（Housman）优美的诗歌，那些挽歌——华兹华斯，关于浪漫主义传统的
which tom you've you've written so well particularly about byron um although he liked to wander the alps didn't he rather than rather than the cotswolds he cleared out of england i was about to say top you say about tom writing about byron but that isn't doesn't your byron turn out to be a vampire tom yeah he does yeah he does he's a rootless cosmopolitan, the very worst kind. But there is a constant pressure on the English landscape. One sees these debates around some of the small rural towns which are being built around. And I think the phrase is donated by new modern estates. And at the same time, young people say, we need somewhere to live.
汤姆，你对此写得非常出色，尤其是关于拜伦的——尽管他喜欢漫游阿尔卑斯山，不是吗，而不是科茨沃尔德（Cotswolds），他撤出了英格兰。我正要说，汤姆，你谈到汤姆写拜伦，但你的拜伦结果不是变成了一个吸血鬼吗，汤姆？对，他确实是，他确实是。他是一个无根的世界主义者，最糟糕的那种。但英格兰的风景一直承受着压力。人们看到了围绕一些小镇展开的辩论，这些小镇周围正在大兴土木。我想这个短语是由现代新住宅区捐赠的。与此同时，年轻人说，我们需要一个居住的地方。
We need more housing. And again, it's one of the tensions that defines the country today. You know, I'm not anxious about a rising population. In many ways, I kind of welcome that sort of boisterous, clamorous exchange of ideas and individuals. You live in Brixham, Tom,
我们需要更多的住房。同样，这也是定义当今这个国家的紧张局势之一。你知道，我并不为不断增长的人口感到焦虑。在很多情况下，我其实挺欢迎那种喧闹、嘈杂的思想和个人的交流。你住在布里克斯顿（Brixham），汤姆，
so you obviously relishish city life dominic is a rural man out in the cotswolds exactly yeah i live in a very bland um suburban town so i do live in brixton which is kind of almost the archetype of of the inner city but i i grew up outside salisbury you didn't i want to feel that those green fields are still there but that's that that's where some of this countryside stuff comes from so i was thinking when jason was talking one of them but one of i mean it used to be famous it's not famous anymore but one of the politically very famous iterations of that was stanley baldwin in the 1920s very much a friend of the show uh england is the country and the country is england or the other way around i can't remember which but he did
所以你显然很享受城市生活。多米尼克是一个住在科茨沃尔德的乡村汉子。完全正确，是的。我住在一个非常平淡的、郊区式的城镇里，所以我确实住在布里克斯顿，这里几乎是内城区的原型，但我是在索尔兹伯里（Salisbury）郊区长大的。你不是吗？我想感觉到那些绿色的田野依然存在，但这就是其中一些乡村情结的来源。所以当杰森在说话时我在想，其中一个——但其中一个——我的意思是它曾经很有名，现在已经不出名了，但在政治上非常有名的一个典型是20世纪20年代的斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin），他是节目的老朋友了，呃，“英格兰就是乡村，乡村就是英格兰”或者反过来，我记不清了，但他做这件事
that at precisely the moment when England was becoming very suburban. You know, his was a message crafted for people listening on radios in new suburban developments who wanted to believe that there was a, you know, their house is called the Larches or something. But as you say, they live, they can't see any larches. And I think that, doesn't that explain England as one of the most densely populated countries in Europe? I think only the Netherlands and Belgium. But absolutely. And you also saw a reworking of Baldwin and indeed George Orwell in some of John Major's speeches late in his premiership. Although indeed another Brixton boy.
恰恰是在英格兰变得非常郊区化的时候。你知道，他的信息是为那些在新的郊区开发项目中收听收音机的人量身定制的，他们想要相信，有一个，你知道的，他们的房子叫“落叶松”（The Larches）什么的。但正如你所说，他们住的地方根本看不到任何落叶松。而且我认为，这难道不能解释为什么英格兰是欧洲人口最稠密的国家之一吗？我想只有荷兰和比利时比它密。但绝对是这样。你在约翰·梅杰（John Major）首相任期后期的一些演讲中，也看到了对鲍德温乃至乔治·奥威尔思想的重新加工。尽管他也确实是另一个布里克斯顿男孩。
Well, he quoted, didn't he? The old maids riding to communion through mists, all that kind of stuff. He did. And shadows stretching across county grounds. And there was a sense of this kind of rural idyll, again, but that plays back to our original idea of something that's lost, something we had, and something we've let go, or has been taken away. It's an anxiety that specifically goes back to the Industrial Revolution,
嗯，他引用了，不是吗？老修女们骑着马穿过薄雾去参加圣餐，所有诸如此类的内容。他确实引用了。还有阴影延伸到郡板球场上。人们有一种这种乡村田园牧歌的感觉，但再次呼唤着我们最初的想法：某种已经失去的东西，某种我们曾拥有、却让我们放手或被夺走的东西。这是一种具体可以追溯到工业革命的焦虑，
I guess. Yes. The more England becomes urbanisedized the more salient the natural world beautiful fields the wildlife all that kind of stuff becomes i mean people may not necessarily go and see it but they want to know that it's there um one other thing jason that you mentioned in the first half that i wanted to come back to because you talk about this quite a lot in the book and i know and i know you you've written brilliantly about it in the past is football so football is one of the most famous english exports
我想是的。英格兰越是城市化，自然世界、美丽的田野、野生动物以及所有这类事物就越发显得重要——我的意思是，人们可能不一定亲自去看，但他们希望知道它们还在。呃，杰森，你在前半部分提到的另一件事，我想回过头来谈谈，因为你在书中对此谈了很多，而且我知道，我知道你过去曾对此写过精彩的文章，那就是足球。所以足球是英国最著名的出口产品之一，
and football is central to england i mean actually football a lot of our listeners are not um british and they may find this frivolous or mystifying i would argue that football is probably the most single most important vehicle of englishness and you talk in your book about the england about the england football team and, for example, the black players. So there, surely, there is an example of how you can be... I mean, Tom said black English. It's true. It doesn't trip off the tongue as readily as black British does. But there are clearly... I mean, some of the great icons of Englishness, Raheem Sterling is a good example, are black, aren't they? Indeed. And I think the England football team is a mirror in which we can see the changing face
而且足球是英格兰的核心。我的意思是，实际上足球——我们的很多听众不是英国人，他们可能会觉得这很轻浮或莫名其妙，但我认为足球可能是英国性最单一最重要的载体。你在书中谈到了关于英格兰足球队的事情，例如黑人球员。所以，这里肯定有一个例子，说明你可以成为……我的意思是，汤姆说“黑人英格兰人”。这倒也是。它不像“黑人英国人”那样脱口而出。但显然有……我的意思是，一些英格兰特征的伟大偶像，拉heem·斯特林（Raheem Sterling）就是一个很好的例子，他们是黑人，不是吗？确实如此。我认为英格兰足球队是一面镜子，我们在其中可以看到这个国家不断变化的面貌。
of the nation. I think football is a real, it's a signifier of so much, but particularly of national identity. I remember going to the England-Scotland match at Euro 96 at Wembley, the famous match where Gascoigne flipped the ball over, was it Colin Hendry? It was Colin Hendry, yes. Slotted home, glorious goal, beautiful, warm, sunny day in London. And when I arrived at the stadium, I remember being absolutely shocked to see so many, the flag of St. George everywhere. Whereas if you look back at footage say of the 1966 world cup at wembley which was england against west germany bobby moore's
我认为足球是一个真正的象征，它象征着很多东西，尤其是国家认同。我记得去现场观看了96年欧洲杯在温布利举行的英格兰对阵苏格兰的比赛，那场著名的比赛中，加斯科因（Gascoigne）把球挑过——是科林·亨德利（Colin Hendry）吗？是科林·亨德利，没错。一脚抽射破门，精彩绝伦的进球，伦敦阳光明媚，温暖宜人。当我到达体育场时，我记得看到那么多圣乔治十字旗到处都是，这让我感到非常震惊。然而，如果你回顾一下比如1966年在温布利举行的世界杯的录像，那是英格兰对阵西德，博比·摩尔（Bobby Moore）的
great team that won won the world cup the crowd everyone's got the union flag even the world cup mascot um the tournament was held in england wears a little um union jack vest i think it's a little lion wears a union jack waistcoat or vest. So the iconography of Englishness was actually British iconography. But suddenly something happened around the time of Euro 96, a year before Blair is elected. And it's not a top-down state-directed process. It's something that comes from below. And one of the means through which it is expressed is football and the English national football team. And for a long time, particularly the late 1970s into the early 80s, English football, the English national football team was associated
伟大的球队赢得了世界杯——人群中每个人拿的都是米字旗，甚至连世界杯吉祥物——那届锦标赛是在英格兰举行的——都穿着一件小小的米字旗背心，我想那是一只穿着米字旗马甲或背心的小狮子。所以英格兰的标志性符号实际上是英国的标志性符号。但突然间，在大约96年欧洲杯前后，也就是布莱尔当选前一年，事情发生了变化。这不是一个自上而下由国家主导的过程。这是发自底层的东西。而它表达的途径之一就是足球和英格兰国家足球队。在很长一段时间里，特别是在20世纪70年代末到80年代初，英格兰足球、英格兰国家足球队与流氓行径联系在一起，尤其是某种极右翼派别、种族主义派别。当英格兰队出国比赛时，曾发生过一些可怕的暴力事件。我记得约翰·巴恩斯（John Barnes）在巴西打进过一个伟大的进球，那是80年代初的英格兰对阵巴西，我想。约翰·巴恩斯，这位曾效力于沃特福德和利物浦的黑人边锋，他打进了一个精彩的单刀球。而一些跟随英格兰队去巴西的暴徒却说，英格兰是以1比0而不是2比1赢了比赛，因为其中一个进球是一个黑人进球的。我的意思是，这是一个骇人听闻的言论。但快进到今天，特别是我们在去年夏天亲眼目睹的2020年欧洲杯（因疫情推迟了一年），我们看到了英格兰国家认同的一种奇妙繁荣，通过英格兰足球队表现出来，
with hooliganism, but particularly sort of far right factions, racist factions. And there was some terrible violence when England went overseas. I remember there was a great goal that John Barnes scored in Brazil, England-Brazil in the early 80s, I think. John Barnes, the black winger who played for Watford and Liverpool, he scored a wonderful solo goal. And some of the thugs who had followed England to Brazil said England had won the match 1-0 rather than 2-0 because one of those goals had been scored by a black man. I mean, a monstrous comment to have made. But fast forward to the present day, particularly what we witnessed last summer, Euro 2020, but delayed by a year because of the pandemic. We saw this kind of wonderful flourishing of English national identity as expressed through the English football team
我们的许多核心球员都是黑人英格兰人，他们非常自然地拥抱圣乔治十字旗，把自己包裹在圣乔治十字旗中。拉什福德（Rashford）本人对一种仁慈的英格兰性有着非常强烈认同，我认为英格兰非常幸运，在这些两极分化、动荡和混乱的岁月里，他们有加雷斯·索斯盖特（Gareth Southgate）作为他们的教练，他是一个非常深思熟虑的人，对英格兰国家认同有过非常深刻的思考。我想在2018年俄罗斯世界杯期间，索斯盖特曾说过，我们英格兰人在我们的身份认同上有点迷失了。我希望通过我年轻的团队，因为他们的年轻和多元，我们可以提供另一种对英格兰性的愿景。我的意思是，特雷莎·梅（Theresa May）当时不会这么说，杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）当时也不会这么说，
with many of our leading players being black English players and they were very comfortable embracing the flag of St George, wrapping themselves in the flag of St George. Rashford himself identified very strongly with a sense of a benevolent Englishness and I think England are very fortunate that through these years of polarisation and upheaval and turmoil, they've had Gareth Southgate as their coach, who is an extraordinarily thoughtful man, and has thought very deeply about English national identity. I think at the time of the 2018 World Cup in Russia, Southgate said that we, the English, had been a little bit lost in our identity. And I hope through my young team, because of their youth and their diversity, we can offer another vision of Englishness. I mean, Theresa May wouldn't say that, Jeremy Corbyn wouldn't say that at the time,
但索斯盖特倾向于探讨围绕英格兰性和身份认同的辩论。然后在去年夏天欧洲杯前夕，他在《球员工会专栏》（The Players' Tribune）上发表了一篇名为《致英格兰》（Dear England）的文章，试图解决汤姆你提到的关于“黑人的命也是命”辩论以及他的球队单膝下跪的争议。他将自己定位在某种传统之中。他的祖父曾在第二次世界大战中服役。他谈到了他对女王、君主制、军队的热爱，但与此同时，他也谈到了他对更进步事业的拥抱。我认为这是一篇非常棒的文章，论证得十分精彩。他基本上是在说，多元与传统可以并行不悖，它们不必是互斥的。一个可以以积极和建设性的方式为另一个提供信息。
but Southgate leaned into the debates around Englishness and identity. And then just before the Euros last summer, he wrote an essay, which was published on the Players' Tribune, called Dear England, which was an attempt to address, Tom, the controversies around the Black Lives Matter debate and his team taking the knee. And he located himself in a tradition. His grandfather had served in the Second World War. He spoke about his love of the Queen, of the monarchy, of the military, but at the same time, spoke about his embrace of more progressive causes. And it was a fantastic essay, I thought, and wonderfully argued. And what he was basically saying was, diversity and tradition can go together, they don't have to be mutually exclusive. One can inform the other in positive and constructive
我认为索斯盖特的英格兰队比大多数人做得更多，将许多人团结在对进步的英格兰性的认同背后。但是杰森，对于足球折射英格兰这面镜子，如果用一种稍微有点调侃的视角来看，那肯定会是：对大多数球迷来说——我意识到你们两个都比我更热衷于足球——但我想俱乐部最终可能比国家队重要得多，而对于这些俱乐部来说，有一种想法是：用跳线作门柱、在本地长大的男孩们，
ways. And I think Southgate's England have done more than most to unite many behind the sense of progressive Englishness, I think. But Jason, a slightly more jauntous take on the mirror that football holds up to England would surely be that for most fans, and I'm aware that both of you are much keener fans than I am, but I would guess that clubs are much more important ultimately than perhaps the national team and those clubs there's the idea that jumpers for goalposts local boys growing up
穿过各个梯队，然后为他们当地的球队效力——我的意思是，这就是俱乐部球队所体现的幻想，而且这是一个完全的幻想，正如你很清楚的那样，因为基本上俱乐部，特别是呃，绝对顶级的俱乐部，基本上正如我们最近看到的，是各种窃国大亨和寡头去……你知道的，去清洗他们肮脏内衣的一种途径。在某种程度上，足球体现了小镇居民对全球化的一切感受。曾经属于地方的一切，现在都成了全球化这个巨大运转机器中的一个小齿轮。在杰森插话之前，难道那场超级联赛的风波不正是这样吗？
going through the the various squads and then playing for their local team I mean that's the kind of the fantasy that club teams embody and it is a complete fantasy as as you well know because basically the club particularly uh the um the absolute elite clubs are basically as we've been seeing very recently ways for various kleptocrats and oligarchs to um you know to to wash their their dirty linen in a way football is the embodiment of everything that the little man out in the provincial town feels about globalisation. That everything that was local is now a tiny cog in the great churning machine that is globalisation. Just to jump in before Jason, isn't that what that Super League furore,
那是一个非凡的时刻，我的意思是，在几天内这是一个如此巨大的故事。难道那没有概括这一切吗，汤姆？那种根深蒂固的英格兰事物被掏空并即将失去的想法，地方特色即将被精英阶层、某种财阀精英阶层这种想法彻底压碎的想法。但同时，我的意思是，当切尔西在阿布拉莫维奇被制裁后不久对阵纽卡斯尔时，有一场比赛，
which was an extraordinary moment, I mean, such a huge story for a few days. Isn't that what it encapsulated, Tom? The idea that something profoundly English had been hollowed out and was about to be lost, and the local was about to be utterly crushed by this idea of an elite, a sort of plutocratic elite but but also i mean there was a match when um chelsea played newcastle just after abramovich had been sanctioned
是的，约翰逊正准备飞往沙特阿拉伯去恳求他提供更多石油，与此同时，你知道的，有81人在沙特阿拉伯被处决，那种感觉是，你知道的，这两支拥有忠实球迷基数的伟大历史球队，都沦为了这些可怕之人的玩具，我认为这是一个相当令人清醒的时刻。我也这么认为，汤姆，我认为俱乐部的水平——当然是英超联赛的最高水平，英超联赛可以说是“放任自流、贪婪的自由市场全球化”的终极体现之一。但俱乐部本身是英格兰今天在全世界最广为人知的事物之一——我的意思是，中国的所有人都知道曼联和利物浦。但这也就是为什么国家队如此重要，因为呃……它独立于俱乐部之外，你知道的，它不属于某个海湾独裁者或俄罗斯的——他们叫什么来着？寡头——。霍布斯鲍姆（Eric Hobsbawm），这位历史学家说过，
and yeah johnson was about to fly out to saudi arabia to to beg him for more oil at the same time as um you know 81 people had been executed in saudi arabia and the the sense that you know these two great historic teams with their devoted fan bases were both the toys of these kind of terrible people was i thought a kind of quite sobering moment i think so tom i think i mean the club's certainly the highest level of the premier League, the Premier League is kind of one of the ultimate expressions of let it rip, rapacious, free market globalisations. But the clubs themselves is one of the things for which england is best known today around the world i mean everyone in china knows manchester united and liverpool but that's also why the national team matters because um it's separate from the clubs you know it's not owned by a a gulf autocrat or a russian um what are they called oligarchs um hobsbawm eric hobsbawm the historian said it said something
他喜欢说的一句话是：“由数百万人的想象共同体，作为一个由11个具名人员组成的团队似乎变得更加真实。”你在板球运动中也能看到这一点，汤姆，我的意思是，你是一个超级球迷。好吧，所以，但是杰森，我想对此说的是，呃，我的意思是，几乎每个国家都有一支足球队，都有一支国家足球队——我的意思是，你可以对意大利这么说，你可以对德国这么说，对西班牙这么说，对巴西这么说。我的意思是，你可以对世界各国的队伍这么说。支持你的国家队有什么特别“英格兰”的地方吗？没有，但我们正在讨论的是英格兰队如何成为不断变化的英格兰民族的表达。这是一个有争议的身份认同。我想如果我们不相信这是一个有争议的身份认同，我们
i like he said the imagined community of millions seems more real as a team of 11 named people and you see that too in cricket tom i mean you're you're a great fan okay so what but jason what i'd say about that is that um i mean pretty much every country has a football team has a national football team i mean you could say that about italy you could say it about germany say it about spain you say about brazil i mean you could say that about Italy, you could say it about Germany, you could say it about Spain, you could say about Brazil. I mean, you could say that countries across the world. Is there anything particularly English about supporting your national team? No, but what we're talking about is how the England team is an expression of the changing English nation. And it's a contested identity. I think we wouldn't
就不会进行这场对话了。而足球一直是——英格兰国家足球队一直是我们在努力应对这种有争议的身份认同的方式之一，也是我们开始理解国家如何发生变化以及今天的英格兰人是谁的方式之一。你说得对，汤姆，正如你一开始所说的那样，我的一些黑人朋友，特别是在80年代和90年代，对黑人身份和英格兰身份感到非常不自在。他们首当其冲地会将自己描述为黑人英国人。对他们来说，那是一个截然不同的身份。但我们在近期看到的，在我看来令人高兴的是，一种黑人英格兰身份正在形成。
be having this conversation if we didn't believe it's a contested identity. And football has been one of the, the English football national team has been one of the means by which we have grappled with this contested identity and also begun to understand how the nation has changed and who the English are today. You're right, Tom, when you said at the beginning, some of my black friends, particularly in the 80s and 90s, were very uncomfortable about blackness and Englishness. And they would describe themselves as black British, first and foremost. That was a distinct identity for them. But what we've seen in recent times, delightfully in my view, is a black English identity developing.
我认为这全部都是好事，我对此表示欢迎。我能稍微改变一下焦点吗？所以我们从奥威尔开始，他的政治立场实在难以捉摸，但为了争论起见，我们暂且认为他最初是个左翼人士。你主编了一本传统上被视为中左翼的杂志。在你的主编生涯中，我想你一直刊登相关文章。我的意思是，我写过——我自己就写过一篇——关于左翼与英格兰性以及英格兰性所存在的问题，关于这种需求的文章——人们
And I think that's all for the good. And I welcome it. Can I change the focus a little bit? So we started with Orwell, who, I mean, he's politically so hard to pin down, but let's just say for the sake of argument, at least initially a man of the left, you edit a magazine that's traditionally been seen as left of centre magazine. And for as long as you have edited it, I think you have run stories. I mean, I've written, I wrote one of them myself, about the left and Englishness and the problem with Englishness about the need, I mean, people
在2010年代初所谓的“蓝色工党”（blue labour）时期就一直在争论这个。你在书中谈到了某种“工党英格兰”（Labour England）的消亡。你认为左翼在英格兰还有卷土重来的可能吗？与英格兰一起，我猜，或者因为正如我们刚才所说的那样，当然有许多左翼人士对英格兰和英格兰性的概念本身感到不安，他们不喜欢它——那么他们如何才能重新赢回这一点？是的，我认为，我认为这是一个巨大的挑战，对左翼来说是一个巨大的挑战，尤其是对工党而言，因为工党曾经在苏格兰非常强大，它在那里确实占据了霸权地位。在2015年的大选中，埃德·米利班德（Ed Miliband）带着41个议席进入那场大选，其中许多人现在都成了民族主义者，他们拥抱了苏格兰民族党（SNP），不仅因为苏格兰民族党掌权并控制着资金，而且因为围绕权力和政府建立的所有机构现在都掌握在民族主义者手中。那么工党必须做什么？如果工党要在英国再次赢得多数席位，
were arguing about this with the so-called blue labour moment at the beginning of the 2010s. And you talk in the book about the sort of the death of a kind of Labour England. Do you think there is a kind of way back for the left in england and kind of with england i suppose or because of course there as we said earlier there are so many people on the left for whom the very idea of england and englishness is is unsettling and they don't like it um so how do they get that back yes i think i think it's a huge it's a huge challenge for the left and particularly for the labour party because the labour Party was once so strong in Scotland, where indeed it was hegemonic. In the 2015 general election, Ed Miliband went into that election with 41 of the, many of them are now nationalists, and they've embraced the SNP, not least because the SNP have power and are in control of the money. And all the institutions that are built around power and government are now with the nationalists. So what does Labour have to do? If Labour is ever to win a majority
它就必须开始在英格兰赢得胜利。但我们在上届大选中特别看到的是，工党在其许多传统的腹地——英格兰北部、米德兰兹——遭到了一场巨大的拒绝。你知道，它在埃塞克斯（Essex）也赢不了，我就是那里的人。我认为埃塞克斯没有一个工党选区。但如果它要再次开始获胜，它必须重新与其许多传统选民建立联系。那些希望——你知道的，工党，工党成立的初衷是代表劳工利益、有组织的劳工，但它始终是有组织劳工与你可能会说是费边社（Fabian）或汉普斯特德（Hampstead）知识分子之间一个并不舒适的联盟。那些喝西梅汁的人。
again in the United Kingdom, it has to start winning in England. But what we saw at the last general election in particular was a huge rejection of the Labour Party in many of its traditional heartlands, in the north of England, in the Midlands. You know, it can't, it loses in Essex, where I'm from. I don't think there's a single Labour constituency in Essex. But if it's ever to start winning again, it has to reconnect with many of its traditional voters. Those who want, you know, Labour, the Labour Party was founded to represent the Labour interest, organised Labour, but it was always an uneasy coalition between organized labor and what you might say the Fabian or Hampstead intellectual. The prune juice drinkers.
是的。无论你如何称呼这些人，他们在1913年创立了《新政治家》（New Statesman）杂志。但那个联盟即使没有彻底破裂，也已经四分五裂了。工党在城市里非常强大——在伦敦、曼彻斯特、利物浦、剑桥、牛津。它在受过教育的城市中产阶级中很强，但在其他所有地方都非常弱。这不是一个能赢得大选的稳定联盟。我的意思是，关于英格兰有一件事确实让我印象深刻，我想你可以更广泛地将其应用于过去10年的英国，我的意思是，这显然是一个非常非常动荡、喧嚣、令人筋疲力尽的时期，对各行各业的广泛人群来说，由于各种
Yes. Whatever you call those people, they founded the New Statesman in 1913. But that coalition, if not definitively broken, is fractured into multiple pieces. And Labour is very strong in the cities, in London, in Manchester, in Liverpool, in Cambridge, in Oxford. It's strong among the educated, urban middle class, and very weak everywhere else. And that's not a stable coalition to win. I mean, one of the things that does strike me about England, and I think you could say Britain more generally over the past 10 years, I mean, it's clearly been a very, very convulsive, turbulent, exhausting period, and very upsetting for a broad range of people for all different
不同的原因，这也是一段非常令人不安的时期。但我认为你也可以说，这也是对英格兰和不列颠对民主原则承诺的肯定。因为我们已经看到了民主可以有多么动荡。我们经历了两次存在主义的全民公投。我们针对我们所生活的国家的组成进行了公投。我们又针对英国运作所处的、最重要的外交事务背景进行了公投。我们对这两者都进行了公投，并且我们都遵守了公投结果。而且，无论人们可能对议会制和简单多数票当选制（first past the post）提出多少批评，它确实促成了某些相当激进的
kinds of reasons. But I think you could also say that it's been an affirmation of the commitment of England and Britain, perhaps more generally, to principles of democracy. Because what we've seen is how turbulent democracy can be. We have had two existential referendums. We've had one on the very makeup of the country that we live in. And we've had another on the most significant foreign affairs context within which Britain had operated. And we have had referendums on both, and we have abided by the results on both. And also, however much criticism one might level at a parliamentary system, and first past the post, it has facilitated the articulation of some quite kind of radical
立场的表达。所以无论是苏格兰的苏格兰民族党，还是奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）——你曾称他为近代史上最具影响力的政治人物，尽管他从未担任过国会议员，或者是科尔宾，并为工党左翼的更远端发出了声音。所以，你难道不能说，在某种程度上，尽管工党的情况看起来可能很黯淡，但一切仍未尘埃落定吗？因为目前我们正处于过山车般的局势中，我们还不太清楚究竟会驶向何方。是的，所有这些都是。我认为“意料之外，情理之中”。我认为英国脱欧之所以对认知精英（用大卫·古德哈特David Goodhart的话说）造成如此巨大的冲击，正是因为它如此出乎意料。奥威尔在我们整个播客中反复引用的那篇essay中，
positions. So whether that's the SNP in Scotland, whether that is Nigel Farage, who you have cited as perhaps the most influential political figure in recent history, even though he's never been an MP, or Corbyn, and giving a voice to the further reaches of the Labour Party on the left. So couldn't you say that, in a sense, although things may look bleak for Labour, they're still all to play for? Because at the moment, we're on such a roller coaster, we don't quite know where we're going to get to. Yes, I think all of that. I think expect the unexpected. I think the reason Brexit was such a shock for the cognitive elite, to use a David Goodhart phrase, was because it was so unexpected. Orwell, in the essay we've cited throughout this podcast,
使用了一个短语，当普通人的声音被听到时，精英阶层会感受到来自底层的拉力。在脱欧公投期间，他们的声音当然被大声且清晰地听到了。这太令人震惊了。它将大卫·卡梅伦（David Cameron）扫出了权力宝座。它最终将鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）送进了唐宁街10号。这是一次民主的实践。如果我说实际上其他欧盟国家也对类似问题进行过公投，而当选民给出错误结果时，他们却被告知再去投一次票，这算不算我过于民族主义？他们确实被告知再去投一次票，这正是许多狂热的留欧派所希望的，
uses a phrase about the elites receiving a tug from below when ordinary people are heard. And they were certainly heard loud and clear during that Brexit referendum. And it was such a shock. It swept David Cameron out of power. It brought Boris Johnson ultimately to 10 Downing Street. And it was an exercise in democracy. Am I being overly nationalist if I say that actually other European Union countries had referendums on similar issues and when the electorate delivered the wrong result, they were told to go and vote again? They were told to go and vote again, indeed, which was what a lot of ardent Romanians wanted,
不是吗？他们希望选民重新考虑，他们想要第二次公投。但是，像大卫·卡梅伦那样，就英国外交政策中如此重要、如此根本的部分——换句话说，就是欧盟成员国身份——通过单一的二元全民公投做出决定，这是一次非凡的冒险行为，不是吗？嗯，确实如此。确实是。但是，正如苏格兰公投一样，从某种意义上说，
didn't they? They wanted the electorate to think again and they wanted the second referendum. But to decide such an important fundamental part of British foreign policy, in other words, membership of the European Union on a single binary plebiscite as David Cameron did, was an extraordinary exercise in risk-taking, wasn't it? Well, it was. It was. But again, as with the Scottish referendum, in a sense,
这些都是各政党在大选中作出的承诺。因此，你可以说，这表明英国民主正在运作，因为法拉奇显然是一个庞大选民群体的代言人，而这个群体并没有被任何主要政党所代表。然而，英国民主的作用是举行了一次公投。为了给这件事加上一层更为历史性的视角，难道没有这样一种感觉吗——每当我回顾过去这——我们在谈论什么，大概七、八年——的政治时，总觉得这一切都非常具有18世纪的风貌。它喧闹、充满活力。它通常非常粗俗，而且——各方都有不良行为。有示威活动。
these were commitments that had been made by parties in general elections. And so therefore, you could say, well, it shows that British democracy is working because Farage was obviously the spokesman for a vast constituency of people who were not being represented by any of the major political parties. And yet British democracy served to give a referendum. Just to give a sort of more historical spin on that as well, isn't there something, I always think when you look back at the politics of the last, what are we talking, sort of seven or eight years, there's something very 18th century about it all. It's rambunctious, it's boisterous. It's often been very vulgar and very – there's been bad behavior on all sides. There have been demonstrations.
但甚至连辩论的性质，你知道，英国是例外的还是欧洲共同体的一部分？还有城镇与乡村。城镇与乡村。我的意思是，这些全都是——还有历史学家罗伯特·图姆斯（Robert Tooms）等人所谈论的气质冲突，持异见的辉格党式中产阶级，以及某种托利主义，也就是英格兰性中约翰逊博士（Dr. Johnson）和约翰·布尔（John Bull）式的一面。我的意思是，所有这些对于1760年或1770年左右的某个人来说都是一眼就能认出来的，你不觉得吗？我是这么认为的。正如对思想自由交流的感觉一样，咖啡馆以及在小酒馆和公共出版物中发生的喧闹辩论。我认为这是一个非凡的时期。汤姆是对的。这段时期动荡、喧闹、令人不安。我们已经深度两极分化。接下来会发生什么？我认为这才是问题所在。汤姆，最终我们会在苏格兰举行第二次公投吗？
But even the nature of the arguments, you know, is Britain exceptional or is Britain part of a European community? And town and country. Town and country. I mean, these are all – and the sort of the clash of temperaments that people like Robert Toombs, the historian Robert Toombs talk about, the dissenting Whiggish sort of middle classes and the sort of Toryism, the kind of Dr. Johnson, John Bullish side of Englishness. I mean, all of that would be instantly recognizable to somebody in 1760 or 1770 or something, don't you think? I do. And as would the sense of an open exchange of ideas, the coffee houses and the boisterous debates that took place in the taverns and in the public prints. And I think it's been an extraordinary period. And Tom's right. It's been turbulent, it's been boisterous, it's been unsettling. We've been deeply polarized. And what comes next? I think that's the question. Do we have, ultimately, Tom, a second referendum
苏格兰民族问题会卷土重来并最终击碎英国国家吗？还是会被无限期推迟？我不知道。但我不认为这段动荡期已经结束。我的感觉是，如果民族主义者目前无法突破50%的得票率，老实说，我看不出他们以后还能怎么做到这一点。民调会给出答案的。时间会证明一切。多米尼克关于18世纪的观点很有趣。奥威尔在他的essay中说，1840年的英格兰与1940年的英格兰能有什么共同点？但是，你和你母亲放在壁炉架上的那张五岁孩子的照片又有什么共同点？奥威尔说，什么都没有，除了你们碰巧是同一个人。是的，我喜欢那段话。我太喜欢了。我认为这正是让我感兴趣的地方，也是我试图在书中探讨的内容，即这种“变化的永恒性”。贯穿时间的、将英格兰的现在与更深厚的
in Scotland? Does the Scottish national question return to break the British state decisively? Or will it be indefinitely delayed? I don't know. But I don't think this period of turbulence is over. I mean, my feeling is that if the nationalists can't get past 50% at the moment, I can't see them ever doing it, to be honest. In the polls, time will tell. Time will tell. Dominic's point about the 18th century is an interesting one. Orwell in his essay says, what can the England of 1840 have in common with the England of 1940? But then, what have you in common with the child of five whose photograph your mother keeps on the mantelpiece? Orwell says nothing, except you happen to be the same person. Yeah, I love that passage. I love that. And I think that's what interests me and what I've attempted to explore in the book is this sense of a changing changelessness. What are these continuities through time that connects the English present with the deeper
英格兰过去连接起来的连续性究竟是什么？这就是为什么我对我们在广告休息前触及的悖论的相互作用如此感兴趣。我认为关于“变化的永恒性”的某种特质定义了我们今天的身份。所以用约翰尼斯·布尔（John Bull）的话来说，这真的是“一切皆变，一切不变”（plus ça change）。杰森，非常感谢。这是一次精彩绝伦的演讲。确实如此。
English past? And that's why I'm so interested in the interplay of paradoxes that we touched on before the ad break. And I think something about changing changelessness defines who we are today. So it really is plus un change, as John Bull would put it. Jason, thanks so much. That was a brilliant tour de force. It was.
太精彩了。杰森的书是《我们现在是谁？现代英格兰的故事》（Who Are We Now? Stories of Modern England）。我极力向大家推荐。它让你为生活在一个充满悖论的国家感到自豪。非常感谢你，杰森。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。再见。
It was wonderful. And Jason's book is Who Are We Now? Stories of Modern England. And I can't recommend it too highly. And it makes you proud to live in a country full of paradox. Thanks so much, Jason. Thanks all for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
评论、一点八卦花边的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票的权益，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想要收听无广告築目、额外皀目以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文本字幕中的任何厕句即可留下评论。